Ich war auf dem Flugzeug aus LA, als ich einen von ihnen gesehen habe, die sich über den Eil befestigt. Computer, ein solches High-Tech-Lingo. Wenn sie etwas nicht verstanden hat, dann gab es nur eine Scanner-Scan. Wir haben meistens über ihren Freund gesprochen. Dieser Typ war nie in einem schlechten Stil. Wechseln.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 154. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier geht's wieder weiter. Im Programm mit Technik. Genau. Es soll mal wieder einen Einblick geben, einen größeren Einblick in so ein Thema, was ich sag das zu häufig oder? Seit Ewigkeiten auf meiner Liste steht. Aber ich glaube, über die Sendung ist jetzt auch schon gut ein Jahr drüber gegrübelt worden. Dementsprechend sollten wir ja auch zu bestimmten Ergebnissen kommen können. Kurz gesagt, es geht um digitales Audio. Wie kriegt man Klangwelten und Computer zusammen? Das ist, denke ich mal, so die Kernfrage. Und um dieser Frage so ein bisschen auf den Grund zu gehen, begrüße ich Daniel Mack. Hallo. Du bist ja schon mal hier gewesen.
Ja, schon zweimal, soweit ich mich erinnern kann.
Zwei Mal? Ah ja, richtig. Wir haben uns ja auch ausführlich über E-Mail unterhalten.
Und über USB, ganz genau.
Das war bis vor kurzem ja noch die längste Sendung mit dem E-Mail.
Wir wurden geschlagen?
Ja, um zwei Minuten.
Mit?
Mit dem Cosmos, der war dann doch ein bisschen interessanter als E-Mail. Aber auch die USB-Folge erfreute sich größter Beliebtheit, denn du hast da ja auch einigen Einblick, weil du eben viel mit Software und Hardware konkret zu tun hast, viel auf Treiberebene, Systemebene hin und her hackst. Aber neben USB ist ja auch Audio bei dir ein wichtiges Feld. Du hast das ja auch mal gelernt, ne?
Ich habe das tatsächlich mal gelernt, ja. War mal zwei, drei Jahre auf so einer Privatschule. Hab das gelernt.
Du bist doch der Einzige, den ich kenne, der dann immer noch direkt neben seinem Programmierterminal immer noch ein Schlagzeug stehen hat, um irgendwie die Kreativität zu überbrücken.
Länger nicht mehr, leider. Länger nicht mehr.
Er hatte echt was so von Coding Monkey im eigentlichen Sinne. Good, anyway, ich meine, du bist ja schuld, ne? Du hast das ja mal aufgebracht, die Idee. Und ich fand die ja ganz super. Mal so das Problemfeld Digital Audio zu bearbeiten. Ich habe da ja meine ganz eigenen Erfahrungen mitgesammelt. Man ist ja so als Computer-Nerd immer erst mal so voll auf diesem, na ja klar, mit Computer und dann ist das alles digital, keine Verluste.
Genau, alles wird einfacher, alles ein non-linearer Schnitt. Wir machen uns die Welt, wie sie uns gefällt.
Genau, mit der Maus. Und überhaupt toll.
In Wahrheit ist das aber leider so kompliziert, dass man sich wirklich wundert, dass es überhaupt irgendwie hupt.
Also ich habe auch davon geträumt, wie möglichst gleich nach dem Mund digital und dann nur noch das. Und dann habe ich halt mit diversen Seemonstern Bekanntschaft geschlossen.
Man sieht es da im Studio so ein bisschen anders. Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es Bilder im Netz von deiner Kommandozentrale hier? Das ist wirklich absurd, was hier mittlerweile an Technik rumsteht. Fehlt noch, dass du hier sitzt und eine Katze streichelst und wie Doktor Blofeld die Welt in den Untergang treibt.
Ah ja, okay. Eine Katze muss ich mir noch besorgen.
Absurde Kommandozentrale hier.
Findest du?
Naja, gut. Also es ist mehr Technik, als man sich so vorstellt. Aber es funktioniert.
Es ist das Ergebnis eines langen Prozesses.
Ich weiß.
Und an dem stand wirklich ganz zu Anfang eben so diese Erkenntnis, dass wenn man erstmal anfängt, dem Computer das Audio zu überlassen, dass man da so in so diverse Sackkassen rein geraten kann, wenn nicht sogar in Verkehrsunfälle. Und dann gibt es halt dann so Loch Ness Monster mit dem Namen Latenz und Clipping und all so ein möglicher Scheiß. Genau. Und da wollte ich jetzt heute mal so ein bisschen hineinfragen, um auch mal so die Grundlagen zu erarbeiten, bzw. um auch mal zu verstehen, warum denn das eigentlich alles so furchtbar ist und warum denn das irgendwie nicht passt. Audio. Wir hören. Wir hören mit unserem Ohr und da haben wir dann irgendwie so das Trommelfell und so diverse Kleinstmechanik, die so auf Schallwellen reagiert. Und ja, eigentlich ist man nun Jahre und Jahrzehnte lang ganz wunderbar gefahren. Ich hatte ja vor kurzem auch noch diese Synthesizer-Sendung, wo ja überhaupt erst mal, was nicht, hast du die gehört? Hast du gehört? Die war ein bisschen wild, genau. Aber was glaube ich ganz gut dabei rauskam, ist so, wie schön man eben so Audio dann eben mit Strom doch abbilden kann, wie direkt und unmittelbar das irgendwie alles ist. Und überhaupt hat man es im Wesentlichen mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu tun.
Das ist ja schon mal der erste Schritt, dass man es auf eine analoge, aber immerhin elektrisch-elektronische Ebene bringt, das ist der erste Schritt. Ich glaube, wir sollten auch das ganze Thema Akustik generell so ausblenden aus der Sendung, weil das führt einfach viel zu weit. Wir gehen einfach davon aus, ein Audiosignal liegt uns schon in einer elektrischen Form vor, ist schon von einem Mikrofon, welcher Art auch immer, gewandelt worden und drückt sich jetzt in analoger Spannung aus. Über das Thema Akustik gibt es auch wahnsinnig viel zu berichten, aber das würde wirklich jeden Rahmen sprengen.
Naja, das kann man ja sicherlich auch nochmal besprechen, aber klar, das ist nicht so der Fokus. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt mal von unserer unmittelbaren Situation hier ausgehen, weil auch hier tun wir ja im Prinzip nichts anderes, als viel zu rum zu digitalisieren. Wir sprechen also jetzt hier schön in unsere Headset-Mikrofone rein. Das sind dann konkret Kondensator-Mikrofone, die eben sehr schön fein auflösen und eine ganz schwache Spannung erzeugen, die dann nochmal kurz nachverstärkt wird. Aber irgendwann, spätestens, wenn man es auf dem Computer aufzeichnen will, muss das Ganze ja dann digitalisiert werden.
Ja, Digitalisierung läuft nur, also ich meine, welch sollte man den Begriff digital erst mal beschreiben? Und die einfachste und betreffendste Beschreibung von digital ist Wert und Zeitdiskret. Man hat also zu einem bestimmten diskreten Zeitpunkt eben einen diskreten Wert.
Was heißt ein Diskret?
Diskret heißt in Schritte aufgelöst, also in diskrete Schritte, wie ist das in deutsch?
Ich glaube, ich kenne noch eine bessere Bezeichnung für die, eine bessere Erklärung für digital. Bin gespannt. Naja, ich meine, was ist denn der Wortstamm? Also worauf bezieht es sich denn?
Also eine Ziffer, ja.
Nee, digital. Also digital heißt jetzt unverhörlich, wenn man es jetzt aus dem Lateinischen hervorholt, mit dem Finger zeigend. Und bezieht sich also also auf den Finger und was also eigentlich im Digitalen drin steckt, ist die Abzählbarkeit der Dinge. Quantifizierbarkeit, wie man auch sagen könnte, wenn man ein bisschen klüger klingen möchte.
Genau, nur eben auf zwei, in zwei Dimensionen, nämlich zum einen halt in der Digital, also im Falle von Audio. Eigentlich immer. Ja gut, okay. Vor allem im Falle.
Nee, ich meine, es fängt ja mit den Äpfeln an, irgendwie das Unterschied zwischen Griesbrei und so, zwei Griesbrei gibt es halt nicht so, aber zwei Äpfel sehr wohl. Warum? Weil man eben Anfang und Ende eines Apfels dann doch sehr klar erkennen kann. Der ist halt abzählbar. Meistens, genau. Es handelt sich um Apfelmus, dann ist es halt nicht so einfach. Aber heißt es ja auch anders. Aber diese Abzählbarkeit, das ist immer so das Ding. So ist auch mal eine Standard-Fangfrage immer gewesen, wenn man es so mit Studenten zu tun hat, die so mit digitalen Medien arbeiten und so. Ja, was digital heißt, dann kommt sie ganz schön ins Schwimmen. Wie auch immer so. Also diese Abzählbarkeit, die will man jetzt auch haben bei Audio. Bloß die Frage ist natürlich, also wenn man das halt runterbricht, letztlich ja auf Zahlenwerte, ist ja die Frage, wovon muss man eigentlich Zahlenwerte bilden, um Audio darzustellen?
Genau. Also man bildet im Wesentlichen, wenn man jetzt PCM, also Pulse Code Modulated Audio, Video-Signale nimmt, bildet man pro Sekunde eine Anzahl von Samples ab, die zu einem diskreten Zeitpunkt genommen werden und diese Samples selber sind auch wieder digital, insofern auch diskret.
Nicht so schnell mit dem Pferden, also wie muss man sich denn jetzt Klang vorstellen? Also ich habe irgendwas, was klingt, ein akustisches Signal, das wird in Strom dargestellt und dann kennen wir alle, das hat so eine Zappelkurve, was sagt denn diese Zappelkurve aus? Die Zappelkurve sagt aus, dass da die Spannung steigt und die Spannung sinkt und die Spannung drückt die Lautstärke aus.
Richtig.
Also sozusagen die Stärke des Schalls.
Genau. Also im einfachsten Fall nimmt man dann mal ein Sinussignal her, das dann eben in Spannung sich ausdrückt auf einem Ostteleskoper, das eben diesen klassischen Sinusverlauf darstellt. So und das bedeutet eben, dass das bedeutet, dass man nur eine Frequenz hat. Genau, ja klar, bei mehreren Frequenzen überlagern die sich entsprechend, das kann man sich im einfachsten Fall mit irgendwie Knutplotter darstellen, was passiert, wenn man drei Sinussignale überlagert und dann entsteht ein Mischsignal und dieses Mischsignal beschreibt einfach über den Zeitvektor gesehen die Lautstärke des Signals.
Das heißt, die Aufgabe der Digitalisierung von Audio ist im Kern, Lautstärke abzubilden im zeitlichen Verlauf.
Genau.
Das heißt, man muss halt messen, wie laut ist das jetzt gerade und dann reicht es aber nicht einmal pro Sekunde nachzuschauen, weil dann hätte man nichts anderes als, ja, was weiß ich, also bestimmt nicht besonders sinnvoll, also wie oft muss man denn nachschauen, wieviele Werte muss man jetzt bilden, bis man wirklich aus einer Reihe von Lautstärken etwas bekommt, was eben so klingt, wie man das erwartet, wie eben das Original, was man digitalisiert.
Ja, naja, das kommt ein bisschen darauf an, welche Eingangsfrequenzen man erwartet. Ja, also wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass die häufigste Änderungen in diesem Signal sagen wir mal ein Kilohertz sind, also 1000 Mal pro Sekunde ändert sich dieser Wert nur, dann kann man mit weniger Abtastpunkten pro Sekunde arbeiten, als wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man wie bei Audio halt bis in den Kilohertz-Bereich auf jeden Fall noch Dinge darstellen möchte. Unser menschliches Ohr ist in der Lage, bis zu, naja je nachdem wie alt man ist, für Kinder bis 20 Kilohertz etwa zu hören und so im Alter nimmt das dann eben ab und...
Wobei Kinder auch diese wunderbare Eigenschaft haben, bestimmte Frequenzen auch nicht zu hören, obwohl sie furchtbar sind.
Ihre eigenen.
Na, ihr eigenes Geschrei. Ich glaube, das sind nochmal so Sonderfrequenzen, die man irgendwie auch nicht so digitalisieren kann.
Na, es ist ganz interessant, dass unser Ohr auch auf den Frequenzen, die wir selber in der Lage sind zu erzeugen, das spielt dann nachher nochmal eine wichtigere Rolle, auch empfindlicher ist. Also unsere Stimme liegt so etwa bei 4 Kilohertz, kann man sagen, grob, und in dem Bereich ist unser Ohr auch tatsächlich empfindlicher als in anderen Bereichen, was irgendwie evolutionstechnisch sich erklärt. Ja, wie auch immer. Also wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass man eben bis 20 Kilohertz Signale noch darstellen möchte, weil das eben typischerweise das ist, was man irgendwie in Musik und in Signalen, die unser Ohr eben so wahrnimmt, jeden Tag vorkommt, dann braucht man eine Frequenz, eine Abtastfrequenz, die deutlich höher ist als das maximale Signal. Das kann man sich so vorstellen, dass wenn man, also was übrig bleibt nach einer Digitalisierung sind ja nur wirklich diskrete Werte auf einer Zeitachse und diese diskreten Werte müssen ausreichen, um im Nachhinein das Signal, so wie es ursprünglich mal vor der Wandlung existiert hat, so gut wie möglich zu reproduzieren. Es gibt an der Stelle das Nyquist-Theorem, das besagt, dass man mindestens mit der doppelten Abtastgeschwindigkeit arbeiten muss, um ein Signal hinterher reproduzieren zu können.
Das heißt, wenn ich 1000 Hertz abbilden möchte, muss ich mindestens 2000 Mal pro Sekunde die Lautstärke messen?
Genau. Also im besten Falle, das ist ein theoretischer Fall, aber im besten Falle ist es so, dass man, wenn man mit 1000 Hertz hat, also 1000 Hertz bedeutet, dass nach, dass 1000 Mal pro Sekunde ein voller, sagen wir mal, Sinus durchlaufen wird und dieser Sinus hat ein Maximum und ein Minimum und im besten Falle trifft man mit seinen 2000 Kilohertz Abtastfrequenz genau das Maximum und das Minimum dieses Sinus und nimmt genau an diesen Stellen seine Werte.
Kann aber auch sein, dass man es irgendwie gerade so auf halben Wege erwischt.
Es kann auch sein, du kommst bei zwei Nullpunkten raus, ist dann doof.
Das heißt, eigentlich will man schon ein bisschen mehr Atem haben?
Genau. Also eigentlich will man mit deutlich mehr Abtastfrequenz arbeiten als das maximale Signal, das man erwartet. Aber man sagt so grob Faktor zwei, weil ein reiner Sinus ist auch natürlich ein bisschen akkert.
Ein Idealzustand sozusagen.
Ja, aber genau.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt hier so reden und so aufzeichnen, was ist denn so die höchste Frequenz, die ich so erzeugen kann?
Die du mit deiner Stimme hast?
Ja, die wir jetzt hier so angenommen, ich würde jetzt hier so ein bisschen zumertreiben.
Ja, das sind ein paar Kilohertz. Also man geht in der Regel davon aus, eigentlich auch ein bisschen fälschlicherweise und ein bisschen altlastbehaftet davon aus, dass ab 20 Kilohertz dann einfach mal Schluss ist. Und deswegen sammelt man in der Regel…
Also beim Hören, nicht beim Sprechen.
Ach so, ja beim Hören.
Ich bezog mich gerade aufs Sprechen.
Ich weiß nicht, was du mit deiner Stimme in der Lage bist zu erzeugen, aber mehr als ein paar Kilohertz werden es nicht sein.
Okay, 6, 7, 8.000.
Ja, vielleicht noch 10, 12.
Aber auf jeden Fall nicht 20, das kriege ich nicht hin.
Genau. Es sei denn, man betrachtet noch die Oberschwingungen, die dann auch noch eine Rolle spielen, aber man sagt irgendwie, man orientiert sich bei der Sample-Frequenz daran, was das menschliche Ohr in der Lage ist, aufzufangen und sagt dann irgendwie, bei 20 kHz ist halt Schluss, also samplen wir mit mehr als dem und man hat sich irgendwie bei der Erfindung oder der Einführung der CD als massenkompatibles Format darauf geeinigt, mit 44.100 Samples pro Sekunde aufzuzeichnen bzw. auch mehr Information ist nicht.
Sollen wir nochmal kurz die Begriffe zurechtlegen? Also Abtask-Frequenz, Sampling-Frequenz, das ist alles dasselbe. Wir haben festgestellt, um Audio aufzuzeichnen, zu digitalisieren, also zu quantifizieren in konkrete oder diskrete Werte, wie du sagst, zu übersetzen, muss man eben nach Maßgabe der zu erwartenden Frequenzen mindestens das Doppelte, im Zweifelsfall vielleicht auch noch eher mehr, wenn man irgendwie nicht weiß, was kommt, das Doppelte dieser Frequenz abtasten. Sprich gehe ich davon aus, dass man so bis zu 20.000 Hertz Töne hat im Eingangssignal, muss ich. 40.000 Hertz Abtask-Frequenz, also das Doppelte, nehmen oder mit anderen Worten, ich muss 40.000 Mal pro Sekunde nachgucken, wie laut ist es denn, wie laut ist es denn, wie laut ist es denn, und das muss ich dann messen.
Genau, es ist aber mehr da, also in Musik gibt es natürlich dann Frequenzen, die über dem 20 Kilohertz liegen, das sind dann Oberschwingungen und so weiter, und das große Problem an der Stelle ist jetzt, dass wenn man das komplette Signal so wie es kommt, quasi in den Abtastprozess wirft, dann hat man da Werte drin, dann hat man Signale vorliegen, die über diesen 20.000 Kilo, über diesen 20.000 Hertz liegen und dann kriegt man völlig falsche Messergebnisse. Durch diese Überlagerung vergreift sich dann dieser Abtastalgorithmus. Der nur 40.000 Mal pro Sekunde das Signal anschaut, vergreift sich dann in dem Material und kriegt Oberschwingungen mit, die hinterher, wenn man es wieder reproduziert, also aus dem digitalen Material wieder ein analoges Material macht, falsche Frequenzen wiedergeben. Und aus dem Grund muss man einen sehr scharfen Filter applizieren, der bei 20.000 Hertz wirklich dicht macht. Das heißt, alles, was über 20.000 Hertz liegt, wird bei einer Abtastfrequenz von 44.100 Hertz einfach weggeworfen. Dieses Signal wird nicht mehr angeschaut. Alles, was über diesen Frequenzband liegt.
Also bei 44.100 Hertz müsste man dementsprechend bei 22.050 Hertz abschneiden, also bei der Hälfte.
Ich glaube, sie sind ein bisschen tiefer bei der CD, weil sich das irgendwie besser angehört hat. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also es hat sich bewährt, noch mehr Material wegzuwerfen, um den Fehler bei der Abtastung geringer zu halten. Also im Wesentlichen wird das gesamte Signal, das wir da haben, halt verhacktstückt und runtergebrochen auf einen digitalen Datenstrom, der dann pro Sampling-Frequenz nur einen Wert abspeichert. Und das ist dann die zweite Dimension. Wir haben dann die Bit-Tiefe, die Sampletiefe, also in wieviel diskrete Schritte wir dann den momentanen Wert zu jedem Zeitpunkt zerlegen. Da hat sich bei der CD 16-Bit angeboten.
Also 65.536 verschiedene Werte, die man damit abbilden könnte.
Genau, von ganz laut bis ganz leise. Und das ist dann auch die maximale Dynamik, die man darstellen kann. Es gibt dann nicht mehr als von 0 bis eben 65.000 mögliche Werte, die man abbilden kann pro Samplewert.
Ja, jetzt natürlich die Frage, reicht das?
Das ist die Frage, ja, und die Antwort ist eigentlich nein. Das reicht nicht. Also man kann das in dB ausdrücken. dB ist ein Begriff aus der Audiotechnik, ist keine Einheit in dem Sinne, sondern beschreibt nur ein Verhältnis. Dezibel. Und man spricht bei einer Lautstärkenverdoppelung von 6 dB, das rechnet sich über einen Logarithmus, aus dem Quarzienten von den beiden Dingen, die man vergleichen möchte. Und man hat also quasi pro Bit, pro Bit, das man zur Verfügung hat, um einen Wert auszudrücken, hat man eine Lautstärkenverdoppelung. Wenn du ein Bit mehr hast, hast du den doppelten Range.
Bei 16 Bit. Generell.
Also generell hast du halt, wenn du...
Also wenn du mit einem Bit mehr aufzeichnest.
Genau, kannst du die doppelte Dynamik darstellen. Deswegen spricht man davon, dass man ca. 6 dB pro Bit hat. Was dann bedeutet, dass bei 16 Bit hat man etwa 96 dB, die man maximal abbilden kann an Dynamik. So und das reicht eigentlich nicht. Das ist ein bisschen verkant worden, meines Erachtens, auch damals, irgendwann in den 80er Jahren, als die CD.
96 dB reichen nicht.
Also ein klassisches Orchester hat deutlich mehr als das. Ein klassisches Orchester kann locker 100-110 dB Dynamik entwickeln.
Also sozusagen der Unterschied zwischen dem leisesten, was sie von sich geben, zu dem lautesten.
Genau.
Also wenn jetzt Pouker und Trompete und alle hauen mal so richtig schön in die Kessel, versus man hat so Dubioses rumgestreiche und rumgeflöte und einer tippt mal die Triangel an und so weiter. Der Unterschied wäre mit 96 dB nicht ausreichend abbildbar?
Eigentlich nicht. Also eigentlich ist es zu wenig, um das abzubilden. Das spielt in der Realität leider, zumindest in der Popularmusik, irgendwie keine große Rolle mehr, weil die Musik, die wir so täglich an den Kopf geworfen bekommen von diversen Radiostationen, die ist komprimiert bis zum Get-Know, und da merkt man das dann nicht mehr. Bei Audiokompressionen geht man dann her und staucht irgendwie das Lauteste und das Leiste zusammen, damit ein möglichst großer psychoakustischer Schalldruck entsteht. Das klingt dann besser für das Ohr, weil es dann lauter ist.
Wohlgemerkt, wir reden jetzt nicht von der digitalen Kompression zur Datenreduktion.
Die Daten wegschmeißt, sondern wir reden von analoger Audiokompression im Prinzip, die genau diese Dynamik verringert. Also eine Audiokompression in dem Sinne macht Dynamik kleiner. Die schiebt das leiteste und lauteste Signal zusammen.
Genau, das ist ja hier auch sehr wichtig beim Podcast.
Bei Sprache ist es auch wichtig, auf jeden Fall.
Bei Sprache ist es wichtig und bei Radio ist es wichtig und bei Podcasts ist es nochmal besonders wichtig. Weil viele Leute das ja dann auch in Situationen hören, wo es potenziell sehr laut drumherum ist. Und dann hat man also dieses klassische Problem, man möchte den iPod möglichst laut stellen.
Beziehungsweise die Lautstärke der Umgebung verändert sich auch ständig.
Genau, aber man möchte ja sozusagen Hub haben und wenn halt irgendwie das leiste und das lauteste zu weit voneinander entfernt ist, dann kann man das eben nicht mehr beliebig verstärken und wenn es irgendwie ein kleineres Band ist, wo alles beisammen ist, dann kann man eben sehr viel mehr Wum da reinpacken. Das ist so ein ganz klassisches Problem und jeder, der schon mal einen Podcast gehört hat, der zu leise ist, das gab es hier auch im Kanal häufig genug. So, und dann lag es daran. Okay, das war jetzt ein kleiner Aus...
Soll bei dieser Sendung dann nicht passieren.
Genau, ja. Aber wir wollen jetzt gar nicht so sehr über Audio-Bearbeitung oder solche reden, sondern eher so bei diesem digitalen Bereich bleiben. Aber das finde ich schon mal ganz interessante Feststellung. Also 6 dB ist eine gefühlte Lautstärkenverdopplung. Also wenn zwei Signale um 6 dB Lautstärke auseinanderliegen, dann ist das Gefühl doppelt so laut. Und du sagst halt 16-Bit-Wandlung, wie sie auf der CD normal ist, ist eigentlich für High-End-Audio unangemessen. Also wenn man jetzt wirklich das Original so einfangen will, wie es ist.
Ja, also es ist vor allem dann unangemessen, wenn man sich überlegt, dass man bei der, also jetzt in der Studiosituation beispielsweise verschiedene Kanäle gleichzeitig aufnimmt, klassisches Multi-Track-Recording, und dort irgendwie eine sehr hohe Dynamik eben in den einzelnen Instrumenten hat, die, naja, im Zweifel noch nicht mal irgendwie vorkomprimiert sind, sondern man nimmt das Signal, so wie es aus dem Aufnahmeraum kommt, auf und fährt dann hinterher im Studio beim Mischen eben diese ganzen Signale zusammen und erzeugt dann das Endergebnis. Und speziell da sind diese 16-Bit halt eigentlich viel zu wenig. Da möchte man wesentlich mehr Dynamik haben, denn man kann auch diese 96 dB, diese 16-Bit, gar nicht voll ausreizen, weil das große Problem an der Stelle ist, und das ist eines der Hauptthemen vielleicht auch, der Hauptprobleme, ist das Clipping, das auf keinen Fall passieren darf. Also bei analogen Bändern hatte man noch den Effekt, dass wenn man ein Signal zu hoch aussteuert, dann war das Magnetband nicht in der Lage, diese Energie vollständig aufzuzeichnen auf das Magnetband, weil diese Magnetbänder haben irgendwann halt eine gewisse Sättigung. Und diese Sättigung ist aber total harmonisch, insofern, als wenn man da einfach mehr Signal reinpumpt, dann kommt davon halt nicht mehr alles auf das Band an. Das Band hat irgendwann eine natürliche Obergrenze an Magnetisierung und im Prinzip hat man so etwas wie einen Komprimierungseffekt dadurch, dass man ein Signal auf einem analogen Band übersteuert. So nennt man das, oder? Man fährt das Signal in die Sättigung, sagt man dann auch. Und in die Band-Sättigung zu fahren hat dann irgendwie einen warmen Charakter auf einmal. Das hört sich direkt gut an, wenn man das macht, wenn man im analogen Band. Bei einem digitalen Signal ist das absolut tödlich. Weil der Wandler, der sich irgendwie 44.100 Mal pro Sekunde eben das Signal anschaut, hat eben nur einen definierten Bereich, in dem man überhaupt Signale erfassen kann. Und wenn das Signal höher ist, als das, was er erfassen kann, dann muss er den maximalen Wert notieren, quasi an dieser Stelle. Und dadurch kann man sich vorstellen, ist ein Sinus eben nicht mehr, wie man sich einen Sinus vorstellt, sondern da werden oben die Ecken einfach abgeschnitten.
Ach so, Ecken beim Sinus.
Naja, also die Spitzen werden abgeschnitten.
Die oberste Kurve wird quasi zu einer geraden Linie.
Genau, und deswegen, weil man das auf keinen Fall haben darf, weil die Aufnahme dadurch dann kaputt ist, muss man entweder das Signal analog vorkomprimieren, bevor man es überhaupt digital wandelt. Muss man sich überlegen, das macht auch mehr Sinn, als es hinterher digital zu komprimieren, können wir vielleicht später nochmal drauf. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, es darf nicht passieren, und deswegen arbeitet man bei der Digitalisierung immer mit einem Headroom. Das ist so ein Safety quasi, den man einfach einhält, um zu sagen, naja, wenn halt doch irgendwie mal, keine Ahnung, der Schlagzeuger macht halt doch einen Rimschott oder, keine Ahnung, der Protagonist hustet ins Mikrofon.
Was ist denn ein Rimschott?
Ach so, wenn man mit dem Stick das Fell und das Rim, also das, was die Trommel... Die Kante. Genau, gleichzeitig erwischt. Dann gibt es einen sehr percussiven, sehr lauten Knall. Klar. Und man will eben auf keinen Fall, dass dadurch eben die Aufnahme kaputtgeht. Und deswegen steuert man das Signal weit unter der Grenze dessen, was theoretisch möglich ist.
Das heißt selbst, wenn er das maximal Laute erzeugt, was man so erzeugen kann, dass es immer noch in einem Bereich liegt, wo der Digitalwandler nicht abschneidet.
Und genau aus dem Grund kann man eben diese 16-Bit an der Stelle beim Recording eigentlich reichen aus dem Grund halt nicht aus. Beim Endergebnis, wenn man dann genau weiß, was passiert und so weiter, wenn man dann seinen Mix macht, kann man den ganzen Kram nochmal so weit zusammenstampfen, dass es eben mit 16-Bit irgendwo in den hörbaren Bereich kommt, dass es auch gut klingt. Aber bei der Aufzeichnung sind 16-Bit eigentlich nicht genug.
Meinst du, es geht auch für Sprache? Also sind da die Lautstärkeunterschiede auch so enorm?
Ja, na klar. Also bei Sprache arbeitet man eigentlich immer mit analogen Kompressoren, also in der Kette hast du ja hier auch, um eben genauer diesen Effekte über Steuerung zu reduzieren.
Aber meine Frage ging eher, ist 16-Bit da auch kritisch?
Na ja, nicht, wenn man mit Kompressoren arbeitet, sage ich mal. Aber wenn man ohne arbeiten würde, wenn man sich denkt, so ja, in meinem Home-Studio komprimiere ich dann einfach digital und nehme erst mal unkomprimiert auf, dann ist das schon mal ein Problem. Also die manche Gestimme ist schon in der Lage, eine gewaltige Dynamik zu erzeugen, ist sie schon.
Also grundsätzlich kann man sagen, wenn man die Ressourcen hat, weil bei der Aufzeichnung heißt ja, 24 Bit statt 16 Bit, zum Beispiel auch gleich nochmal 50 Prozent mehr Speicherplatz, der da benötigt wird pro Spur, das kann also eine Menge machen. Genauso mit der Sampling-Frequenz, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe, ist ja auch so, dass 44.1, das ist ja wirklich ein bekloppter Scherz, stimmt eigentlich dieses Gerücht, dass das alles an diesem Karajan lag? Naja, es ist so eine Urban Legend, die ich immer gerne hervorhebe, weil ich noch keine andere Geschichte gehört habe, aber dass die 44.1 machen, klingt ja sozusagen so ein bisschen merkwürdig, zumal der Standard im Studio-Bereich 48 Kilohertz, 96 Kilohertz, 192 Kilohertz sind, also Zahlen, die jetzt mal nicht so krumm sind, wo ein bisschen Headroom auch schon mit eingearbeitet ist. 44.1 steht ja sozusagen komplett für sich und ist ja eigentlich erst mit dieser CD geboren worden. Vorher gab es diese Sampling-Frequenz in dem Sinne nicht, weil vorher gab es auch nicht so viel Digital Audio.
Die CD hat das ja auch nur quasi, sagen wir mal, zu haben.
Ich habe diese Geschichte gehört, dass sie durchaus mal 48 Kilohertz haben wollten, dann aber auf 44.1 runtergegangen sind, damit sie irgendwie mehr Audio auf diese CD draufkriegen, weil sie einfach weniger Platz belegen, weil sich Karajan beschwert hat, dass irgendeine Symphonie dann eben nicht mehr draufpassen würde, wenn man dann nur 65 Minuten hat, anstatt die 72 Minuten, die es sonst so erreicht hätte.
Da ist ja immer ein Trade-Off. Die Geschichte kenne ich jetzt nicht, aber klar, man muss sich halt immer überlegen.
Kann auch eine totale Fehlgeschichte sein, aber es ist so eine dieser Geschichten, die finde ich einfach zu schön, dass man wissen möchte, dass sie falsch ist. Aber das wäre zumindest meine Erklärung, warum sie auf so eine komische Zahl gekommen sind. Weil das ist ja auch der totale Scheiß irgendwie, also wenn man jetzt so mit Digital Audio dann hin und her rechnet und so weiter, von 44.1 auf irgendwas anderes zu kommen, ist alles ganz furchtbar.
Ja, es gibt dann auch 88.2, das ist dann irgendwie wenigstens mal die doppelte Audio-Auflösung.
Aber das ist so ein professionelles Digital-Equipment, findet das eigentlich nicht statt, diese Zahl?
Nein, also, ich weiß nicht genau, es gibt natürlich irgendwie zig Ansätze, wie man in Studios arbeitet und ich kenne da auch nicht irgendwie jeden natürlich, aber soweit ich das weiß, wird, wo auch immer es möglich ist, mit 192 Kilohertz 24 Bit aufgezeichnet. Und dann hat man halt eine Menge Material und braucht dann schon echt Plattenstapel, wenn man das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein dreistündiges Konzert irgendwie mit 16 Kanälen irgendwie dann live mitschneidet und das irgendwie über eine ganze Woche oder so und dann sich dann irgendwie eine Live-CD da draus zusammen bastelt. So, das sind halt echt Daten, die da zusammenkommen. Ich würde es jetzt nicht ausrechnen, aber es ist halt nicht gerade wenig Holz, was da irgendwie erstmal ein...
Da denkt man immer, Video wäre so die eigentliche Datensau.
Ja, ist es auch, aber das... Ja, also Audio ist nicht zu unterschätzen.
Genau, naja. Da muss ich auch mal überlegen, ob ich hier vielleicht mit 24-Bit aufnehme. Vielleicht bringt das ja noch irgendwas. Das kann einem ja nicht gut genug zu klingen.
Na ja gut, aber du gehst da am Ende her und machst daraus halt MP3.
Ich mache MP3, aber vorher kommt da auch nochmal so ein Level-Date da drüber, der dann irgendwie auch alles nochmal irgendwie anpasst, uns trennt und nachkomprimiert und um-expandiert.
Das ist ja nicht die Schaden, oder? Es gibt einen Unterschied einfach, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eine Straße lang läuft und man hört Musik, man kann in der Regel sofort sagen, ob diese Musik live gespielt ist oder eine Aufnahme ist, die aus einer PA kommt. Keine Ahnung, hier fehlt der Lammusik in Berlin irgendwo, wenn du da die Straße lang latschst, dann weißt du irgendwie schon zwei Kreuzungen vorher, aha, ist live. Und das liegt schon daran, dass das halt damit…
Meinst du, weiß jeder intuitiv oder weißt du?
Ich würde das behaupten, ja. Dass das jeder weiß.
Ich habe noch nie so viele Gedanken drüber gemacht. Woran machst du das fest?
Ich weiß nicht. Das ist…
Eine Dynamik dann oder was?
Ich würde sagen, das ist auf jeden Fall, ne, das sind eher die Frequenzen, die eben bei normaler Musik, die von CDs kommen, nicht mehr abgebildet werden.
Ohbertöne.
Ja. Also es ist auch so, dass die, dass hier auch bei einer Live-Band dann dieselbe PA dann halt arbeitet, ja. Also das Ausgabe-Medium der Lautsprecher ist es in dem, sind ja nicht unbedingt, sondern es ist schon, es sind einfach die, die Frequenzen, die dem fehlen, diesem Signal. Deswegen ist es nicht ganz akademisch mit diesen Abfassen.
Ich habe mir so noch gar keine Gedanken gemacht, dass man das so raushört. Ich meine jetzt bei dem Prick recordet, wenn das halt so maßlos zusammenkomprimiert ist, also jetzt audio-technisch zusammenkomprimiert ist, dann klingt es halt irgendwie ganz anders. Es ist so ein bisschen so wie Musik aus dem Radio eben. Das ist halt irgendwie monstermäßig zusammenkomprimiert, damit es egal, ob es halt Nachrichtensender, Nachrichtenverkündung gerade ist oder eben von Halen da ihren Top-Song ablassen mit E-Gitarre und Krach, Bum und Hass nicht gesehen. Es klingt halt immer gleich laut, damit nicht jeder zum Radio rennen muss und alle zwei Minuten lang die Lautstärke.
Ja, ja und je nachdem, welcher Radiosender das ist, dann es gibt jeder Radiosender hat quasi seinen Summenlimiter irgendwo im Sendewerk irgendwo stehen und dieser Summenlimiter ist einmal eingestellt von jemandem, der sich da irgendwie psychoakustisch irgendwie Gedanken gemacht hat und der weiß irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein komischer Mixsender, der braucht halt einfach Druck so und das ist jetzt kein Klassik-Sender und weil der Druck braucht, stellen wir diesen Summenlimiter eben so ein, dass er möglichst maximal hinten irgendwie das Maximum an Pegel erzeugt und dieser Summenlimiter, der wird dann einmal eingestellt und kommt dann hinter so eine Rauchglas-Scheibe, wird verblumpt und nie wieder eingestellt, tatsächlich.
Okay, jetzt sind wir doch wieder sehr ins akustische Feld abgegült. Vielleicht fassen wir einfach noch mal kurz zusammen, also Audio will man digital haben, ist ja auch klar warum, weil für Recording und so weiter ist das natürlich alles wunderbar, auch für die Nachbearbeitung hat das alles so seine Vorteile, die möchte man haben, aber es bringt eben auch bestimmte Nachteile mit sich und diese Nachteile sind, ich fasse nur mal zusammen, die Nachteile lassen sich im Wesentlichen darauf reduzieren, dass man eben einerseits das Problem hat, dass man eben mit einer potenziell unendlichen Dynamik irgendwie klarkommen muss, das heißt man muss so den richtigen Range finden und dann auch die richtige Auflösung wählen bei der Wandlung ins Digitale, um eben diese Lautstärkesignale, die auf einen einprasseln, fein genug aufzulösen und eben auch zu verhindern, dass man eben nicht über sein Limit hinausschießt und dann einfach abklippt und dann ist nämlich das Audiosignal richtig im Arsch und dann kann es auch nie wieder gerettet werden.
Genau, und man muss es wirklich auch so sehen, es ist wirklich auch nur eine Annäherung an das, was ursprünglich da mal war. Das ist tatsächlich auch nicht mehr als das, man nimmt irgendwie halt so eine, man nimmt eben n Samples pro Sekunde und nimmt diesen Wert, löst ihn auf in, keine Ahnung, ein paar Bits, 16 oder 24 oder 32 und speichert das eben ab und hofft, dass hinterher bei der Reproduzierung dessen, was da ursprünglich mal gedacht war, etwa das rauskommt, was dann als Eingangssignal mal vorlag. Das ist halt tatsächlich eine Annäherung. Man kann sich irgendwie das Gegenbeispiel klar machen, wenn irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Stones irgendwie im Studio standen und halt aufgenommen haben, dann gab es ein analogisches Signal, das direkt aus den Kondensatoren heraus kam. Das wurde dann irgendwie analog über Operationsverstärker in absurd komplizierten Mischkonsolen verarbeitet und dann am Ende auf ein Band magnetisiert. Das war halt aber immer noch irgendwie das, was die Jungs damit ihre Stimme und ihre Gitarre gemacht haben, war dann quasi in der Repräsentation der Magnetisierung über den Umweg der analogen Spannung eben auf diesem Band. Und am Schluss wurde eben diese analoge Information auf eine Platte gepresst und wenn man die zu Hause auflegt, dann wird eben genau das reproduziert, was da über Mechanik und Magnetismus ursprünglich mal war und was auch noch aus den Lautsprechern kommt, ist eigentlich halt das, was da in dem Studio mal passiert ist. Weil digital ist es dann einfach, dann nimmt man den ganzen Eingangstrom, der da mal ist, irgendwie zerhackt den irgendwie, approximiert das irgendwie so, gut, dass es halt irgendwie geht und soweit das vertretbar ist und wenn man das zu Hause einlegt, dann kommt da halt ein Sinus raus, wo ursprünglich nicht unbedingt ein Sinus war. Also das ist halt schon eigentlich eine ziemliche Vergewaltigung des Audiomaterials, wenn man so möchte.
Aber weil es so praktisch ist, wollen wir natürlich jetzt mal sehen.
Klar, es hat natürlich enorme Vorteile, das will ich gar nicht sagen.
Das liegt ja auch auf der Hand, deswegen reden wir auch darüber. Dieser ganze Bereich ADDA-Wandlung ist ja, haben wir ja schon gesagt, vor allem mit diesem ganzen CD-Playern hochgekommen. In den 80er, 90er Jahren gab es ja auch diverse Weiterentwicklungen. Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal drauf zu sprechen kommen. Also dann fingen irgendwie die CD-Player an, noch toller zu sein oder behaupteten noch toller zu sein, weil sie mit sowas wie Oversampling daherkommen. Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen?
Na ja, bei Oversampling geht es eigentlich, also eigentlich ist es ein Begriff aus der AD-Wandlung. Das heißt, die CD-Player selber haben da gar nicht so viel mit zu tun. Also Oversampling bedeutet, man nimmt mehr Samples, als man hinterher in dem Material, das man ausspielt, tatsächlich repräsentiert. Und damit erzeugt man, also man nimmt quasi, sagen wir mal, doppelt so viele Samples.
Du meinst, das ist bei der Aufnahme?
Bei der Aufnahme.
Na gut, aber die CD-Player sind ja für die Aufnahme nicht zuständig.
Nee, deswegen, also eigentlich ist es ein Begriff, wie gesagt, aus der AD-Wandlung. Man nimmt eben doppelt so viele Samples auf, wie man eigentlich ausspielen möchte und nimmt...
Und für die DA-Wandlung ist es quasi unerheblich?
Für die DA-Wandlung ist es eigentlich unerheblich.
Also ich habe das immer so verstanden, dass die zwischen zwei Werten, die auf der CD stehen, mathematisch quasi da so eine Verbindung sich errechnen. Also sozusagen, ich habe so den Punkt N und den Punkt N plus eins so in der Zeit und die liegen halt so und so weit auseinander und man jetzt irgendwie da sich quasi so eine Linie denkt und sozusagen mathematisch nachvollzieht und dann eben der Wandler, also der DA-Wandler, also der, der aus dem Digitalen wiederum analoges Signal macht, dann einfach zwei oder vier mal so häufig wandeln lässt, dass das Ergebnis dann irgendwie sauberer ist.
Das ist richtig. Also ich weiß noch nicht, habe ich das richtig so? Es muss natürlich eine Verbindung zwischen zwei Sample-Werten geschaffen werden, auch bei der Reproduzierung, sprich bei der DA-Wandlung und im Zweifel, wenn man, ja, ja, also da spricht man auch von Oversimulation richtig.
Es ist die Frage nur, ob das viel bringt. Ich meine, das macht das Ursprungsmaterial nicht besser. Das ist halt sozusagen nur der andere Prozess, weil ja auch der DA-Wandlungsprozess ist ja im Prinzip auch anfällig, weil wenn man das aus dem Digitalen nicht ordentlich analogisch macht, dann ist ja auch blöd.
Ja, also man orientiert sich da eher halt auch an einem Sinus, also an einer geraden Linie. Das heißt, wenn man Samples hat, die quasi minimal sind und maximal und das indirekte Abfolge, dann gehen moderne DA-Wandler eher davon aus, dass das mal ein Sinus war als ein Rechteck. Aber eventuell war es gar kein Sinus und das ist halt genau das Problem. Wir können das dann auch in dem Schritt der DA-Wandlung auch nur noch annehmen. Wir können nur noch raten, naja, das wird wohl dann irgendwie, war es ein Sinus oder war es ein Sägezahn? Die sehen erstmal in dem Material, wie es so vorliegt, in digitaler Form gleich aus.
Das wird halt nicht besser, als es aufgenommen worden ist.
Nee, nee, das kann es nicht werden. Man kann sich nur eben, ja, man kann irgendwie psychokussisch bessere Effekte erzielen, indem man da halt eher von einem Sinus als von einem Sägezahn ausgeht.
Und ist jetzt auch noch so ein Begriff aus dieser DA-Wandlungsgeschichte, irgendwann fing sie an mit so einem, mit Ein-Bit-Wandlern?
Das ist, naja, das ist eigentlich auch eher aus der AD-Wandlung. Also, diese Wandler, diese analog-digital-Wandler arbeiten intern in der Regel alle heute mit, also es gibt verschiedene Methoden, wie man ein analoges Signal in ein digitales verwandeln kann. Es gibt sogenannte Flash-Wandler, die haben einfach eine große Anzahl an Komparatoren und vergleichen das Signal, das sie vorliegen haben, mit Referenzspannungen und sagen dann, das wird etwa so dieses Signal gewesen sein. Die Flash-Wandler sind aber enorm aufwendig herzustellen.
Warum heißen die Flash-Wandler?
Weil ich denke, weil zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt auch wirklich das Ergebnis vorliegt. Wird vielleicht gleich klarer, wenn wir…
Also schnell oder was?
Ich denke, aber genau weiß ich es nicht. Flash-Wandler findet man heute noch in so Oszilloskopen, digitalen Speicheroszilloskopen und so. Da werden glaube ich, so weit ich das weiß, Flash-Wandler eingesetzt, aber die sind meistens auch nicht sehr viel hochauflösender als 8-bittig oder so. Die sind deshalb extrem schwierig herzustellen, weil diese Referenzspannungen schwer zu erzeugen sind. Also wenn man da mit Widerstandsnetzwerken arbeitet, um die Spannungen zu teilen, dann hängt im Prinzip die gesamte Qualität des Audiosignals hinterher von der Genauigkeit dieser Widerstände ab. Und das lohnt sich nicht, also nicht in der Massenmarktgeschichte, wie Digital Audio heute so verwendet wird. Und deswegen verwendet man da eine andere Technologie, die sich Delta Sigma nennt, die im Prinzip vorgeht und ein Signal permanent vergleicht. Also man hat einen Akkumulator und einen Comparator und man vergleicht permanent, ob das Signal, das man irgendwie in letzter Zeit gesehen hat, höher ist oder niedriger ist als das, was man gerade irgendwie als Eingangssignal bekommt und codiert dann mit einem einbittigen Strom eben Einsen oder Nullen am Ende und sagt irgendwie, wir müssen mal irgendwie tiefer kommen, um wieder eine einigermaßen ehrlichere Präsentierung dessen zu haben, was wir am Eingang vorliegen haben. So und dieser Einbittstrom wird dann in der Regel wieder in PCM verwandelt, sprich in eben das, was wir diskutiert haben, in die diskreten Werte N pro Sekunde.
Also PCM, Puls, Modulation. Also das ist sozusagen eigentlich das Sinnbild für Digital Audio, dass man eben Puls, also die Lautstärke, dass man die eben kodiert mit einem Wert darstellt und wenn man irgendwo hinschreibt 44,1 Kilohertz schräg-
16 Bit, dann meint das eben genau das PCM-Signal, das eben 44.100 Werte pro Sekunde mit jeweils 16 Bit kodiert. Man kam aber auf die Idee, dass man diesen Bitstrom, der dabei entsteht, eigentlich auch direkt ausspielen kann und das nennt sich sein DSD. Das ist gar nicht... Direct Stream Digital heißt das. Und es hat vor allem, wenn man die gesamte Kette der Signalverarbeitung anguckt, eigentlich den großen Vorteil, dass am Ende, wenn man ganz am Ende wieder DSD hat, um es zurück zu verwandeln in analoge Signale, hat man in der Regel ja einen Lautsprecher oder einen Kopfhörer, auf jeden Fall irgendeine Kombination aus Magnet und Membran, die ein solches Signal wieder integrieren kann. Das heißt, integrieren im mathematischen Sinn, das bedeutet, dass man eigentlich so ein Einbildsignal direkt auf den Kopfhörer geben kann und dieser Kopfhörer dann die digital analoge Wandlung übernimmt automatisch, indem es das Signal, wenn eben eine 1 kodiert ist, dann lenkt die Membran in eine Richtung aus, bei einer 0 in die andere Richtung und automatisch hat man sozusagen, also in der Theorie, hat man sozusagen eine sehr viel einfache DA-Wandlung am Ende.
Verstehe, das heißt, man bildet sozusagen mit so einem Differenz, mit so einem 01-Differenzsignal eigentlich so den Hoch-Runterverlauf des analogen Audiosignals ab. Geht die Kurve hoch, 11111111, wird sie ein bisschen schwächer, 011111111000 und dann, wenn sie wieder runtergeht, mehr Nullen so, 00100000000 und dann wird es ganz gerade. Verstehe, und das ist dieses DSD, das ist das, was so Super-Audio-CD und solche Nachfolger haben.
Genau, die SACD hat das irgendwie, die sich aber, naja, mal gucken, ob sie das durchsetzt.
Bisher hat sie das nicht getan, ich glaube auch, dass diese ganzen Medien, naja.
Na, das hängt auch mit Hörgewohnheiten zusammen und wie gesagt irgendwie.
Aber wie hoch ist denn dann die Sampling-Frequenz? Also ich meine, die muss ja dann sehr, sehr, sehr viel feiner aufgelöst sein.
Die arbeiten an der Stelle dann mit 2,8 MHz. Also dieses Einbit-Signal ist nochmal wichtig zu erwähnen, ist tatsächlich auch Bestandteil aller Digital, Quatsch, aller Delta-Sigma-Wandler. Diese Delta-Sigma-Wandler, die eben überall eigentlich mittlerweile eingesetzt werden, also alles, was Audio von analog nach digital verwandelt, ist eigentlich ein Delta-Sigma-Wandler heutzutage.
Das ist der Goldsteinert.
Ja, und die haben alle intern eine wesentlich höhere Frequenz, um das Audio-Material wirklich abzutasten. Die machen ein extremes Oversampling, erzeugen sie diesen Einbit-Strom und am Ende spielen sie aber halt PCM aus.
Ah, weil das das ist, was man normalerweise so brauchen kann.
Genau, also da hängt natürlich auch die ganze Postproduktionskette dran. Ja, also wenn man in so einem digitalen Studio arbeitet, dann hat man ja seine Plug-Ins da irgendwie auf dem Rechner und seine, naja, also seine Schnittprogramme und so weiter. Und die gehen eigentlich alle von PCM aus. Und das bedeutet in der Realität, dass dieses Einbit-DSD-Signal, wenn man es in der Aufnahme verwendet, in der Regel auf dem Computer dann, also im digitalen Studio zurückverwandt wird, den PCM, um eben seinen ganzen Park an Effektgeräten gegenwerfen zu können. Und am Ende, je nachdem, kommt dann bei der SACD halt wieder dieses DSD zum Einsatz. Aber die Kette in der Mitte ist in der Regel PCM.
Das heißt, eigentlich wäre diese DSD-Geschichte die bessere Variante der ganzen Digitalisierung?
Ich weiß nicht, man streitet sich da sehr. Also man spricht irgendwie von 120 dB Dynamik und Abbildungen bis 100 Kilohertz und so weiter.
Also 120 dB Dynamik, aber wenn ich jetzt PCM mit 24 Bit mache, hat man das im Prinzip auch. Genau, also wenn man deine Rechnung da mit 6 dB pro Bit rechnet, habe ich von mal ausgerechnet, dass das 144 dB, das ist ja auch schon eine Menge Holz.
Ja, und da ist natürlich auch wieder, da muss man diesen Headroom, diesen Safety wieder reinrechnen und so weiter, aber 144 dB ist rein rechnerisch erstmal auch wieder was, was, naja, was wenige Mikrofone noch in der Lage sind auszugeben.
Brauche ich denn bei diesem DSD diesen Headroom nicht? Ist der in der Lage, mit im Prinzip allen Pegeln klarzukommen, weil er immer nur die Differenz rechnet?
So wie ich das verstehe, ist das tatsächlich so. Also eigentlich kann der nicht ins Clip kommen, der schreibt einfach nur noch endlos eins raus.
Und irgendwann geht es schon wieder runter.
Na ja, gut, man muss halt irgendwie die andere Seite gucken, wie sie damit dann klarkommt. Aber im Prinzip stimmt schon. Im Prinzip, wenn man mal von analogen Vorstufen und so weiter absieht, die natürlich auch ins Clip fahren können, im Prinzip hat man dieses prinzipielle Problem erstmal nicht. In der Praxis hat man es wahrscheinlich dann doch, wie gesagt, weil man natürlich...
Ja gut, müssen ja noch andere Komponenten damit klarkommen, den Strom dann sozusagen überhaupt abzubilden. Aber zumindest ist es nicht so eine harte Kante. Also würde ich jetzt mal so...
Genau, das Prinzip hat eben nicht diesen Maximalwert einfach.
So, jetzt ein anderes Problem, was ja auch immer, also auch schon in der analogen Geschichte mit dabei ist, ist so das Rauschen. Inwieweit spielt das hier bei solchen Wandlungssachen ein Problem? Also, du hast so schön gesagt, na ja, dann kamen die Rolling Stones dann noch direkt ins Magnetband. Das geht natürlich auch von so einer idealen Welt an aus, wo dieses Signal bei seinem ganzen Weg durch alle Kabel und Mischpulte und dann eben auf diesem Tape keinerlei Veränderungen erfährt. Tatsächlich wird es ja permanent verändert, weil es ja durch Medium durch muss und dann natürlich dann alles davon abhängt, wie man so seinen eigenen Rauschen hat.
Rauschen ist ein großes Problem tatsächlich. Vor allem, weil wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, wenn man ein sehr leises, wenn man jetzt quasi ein Nullsignal hat, also man nimmt quasi etwas auf, was keinen Ton von sich gibt, dann hat man, also jetzt ein vereinfachtes Beispiel, dann hat der Wandler, das Rauschen hält sich in dem Bereich auf, dass der Wandler mit seinem untersten Bit quasi darstellt. Dann hat man, weil der Rauschen irgendwie zufällig ist, halt ab und zu den Effekt, dass wenn das Rauschen ein bisschen höher wird, der Wandler dann eine Eins wahrnimmt und wenn es halt runter liegt, nimmt er eine Null wahr. Und wenn man das jetzt irgendwie, wenn man jetzt keine Ahnung, alle 1000 Samples nimmt der Wandler jetzt eine Eins auf und dann irgendwann vielleicht eine Minus Eins, dann notiert er da, gibt das hinten eben so aus und die nächste Stufe sieht dann, aha, da war eine Eins, da war eine Minus Eins, da war wieder eine Eins und da ist über ein paar Samples, das wird wohl ein Sinus gewesen sein. Und also wovon soll er auch ausgehen, weil die Information, dass das Rauschen ist, ist ja weg. Und deswegen wird die nächste Stufe davon ausgehen, dass da ein Sinus war und dieses Sinus wird dann eben keine Ahnung, ob man jetzt jedes 1000. Sample, bei 44.1 zum Beispiel, diesen Fehler hat. Davon ausgehen, dass da ein 4 Kilohertz Sinus war und wird den entsprechend halt reproduzieren. Und 4 Kilohertz ist deswegen halt besonders kritisch, weil wir da, wie gesagt, eben auch besonders empfindlich sind und wir das alle als tatsächliches Störgeräusch wahrnehmen. Aus genau dem Grund geht man her und macht was, was man eigentlich, man muss auch erstmal draufkommen, man mischt Rauschen bei. Und zwar in der Größenordnung von etwa einem halben Sample.
Wer mischt das Rauschen bei?
Beim Wandeln. Beim Wandeln, ja. Man mischt analoges, im Zweifel, weißes Rauschen bei. Jetzt in der, ja, erstmal in der vereinfachten, einfachen Darstellung weißes Rauschen bei, um eben diesen Wandler, wenn da nur Rauschen ist, tatsächlich öfter auszulenken. Dass er öfter mal eine Eins und öfter mal eine Minus Eins schreibt, um hinterher ein mehr oder weniger zufälliges, digitales Signal zu erzeugen, sodass die nächste Stufe an der Stelle nicht von einem Sinus ausgeht, sondern eben von Rauschen, so. Das nennt sich Dithring. Also das spielt dann auch eine Rolle, wenn man zum Beispiel von 24 Bit auf 16 Bit wiedergeht, im reinen digitalen Bereich, wenn man da einfach nur die Samples abschneidet, an einer bestimmten Bit-Grenze, hat man auch da das gleiche Problem, weil man eben mal halt an einer Stelle eine 1 schreibt, wo eigentlich keine 1 war, sondern halt irgendwie keine Ahnung was anderes, und mal eine 0, und deswegen mischt man auch beim, wenn man von 24 auf 16 Bit quasi downsampled, mischt man auch einen Rauschen bei, sondern ein Dissering an der Stelle. Jetzt ist das natürlich nicht optimal, da einfach nur Rauschen beizumengen, und man könnte sich ja auch überlegen, dass man vielleicht dieses Rauschen in irgendwelche Bereiche verschiebt, wo man es nicht so wahrnimmt, also entweder außerhalb unserer Hörgrenze, je nachdem wie hoch man eben wandelt, oder eben außerhalb des Bereichs, der halt besonders unangenehm für uns ist, bei 4 Kilohertz, und da ist es dann ein hochkomplexes mathematisches Verfahren, das sich Noise Shaping nennt, dass eben genau dieses Rauschen, das man beimengt, irgendwie eben nicht zufällig macht, sondern das so gestaltet, dass sich der Fehler in Bereiche verschiebt, wo es nicht so auffällt.
Ich meine, dieses Rauschen, hast du ja gesagt, das tritt dann vor allem so in den leisen Bereichen auf, weil klar, es ist ja Rauschen, es ist eben jetzt erstmal nicht laut, wenn das Rauschen laut ist, haben wir eh noch ein anderes Problem. Und diese Quantisierung beim Digitalisieren für PCM löst ja im Prinzip diese feinen Bereiche genauso oft wie die lauten. Aber die Kleinstunterschiede zwischen den leisen sind ja unter Umständen dann wichtiger als die Kleinstunterschiede bei den lauten. Ist denn das immer so eine lineare Abbildung, also bedeuten, du hast ja gesagt, 1 Bit 6 dB? Okay, aber man könnte ja auch sagen, im leisen Bereich, dass man da so eine Kurve anlegt.
Ja, um Daten zu sparen, macht man das tatsächlich bei so Kodex für Telefonie zum Beispiel. Da wird das eingesetzt.
Um Daten zu sparen. Aber jetzt kommt man jetzt rein als um das akustische?
Na ja, gut, also man geht eben her, sagt man wandelt nur mit 8 Bit, weil mehr ist halt nicht irgendwie auf dem älteren Platz. Und um halt noch mit 8 Bit eine einigermaßen vernünftige Sprachqualität hinzukriegen, verschiebt man quasi die Abstände der einzelnen Bits.
Ach so, ok. Aber ich meinte jetzt eher, wenn man jetzt 24 Bit hat, volles Programm, wenn man einfach mal sagt, ja im unteren Bereich ist dann vielleicht ein Bit nur 1 dB. Also das ist dann sozusagen ein sehr viel feineren Lautstärkebereich abdeckt. Dass man eben dieses Rauschen auch feiner detektieren kann.
Naja, das Rauschen an der Stelle ist entscheidend für das Ergebnis. Wenn du ein lautes Signal hast und dort eben diesen Messfehler des Wandlers hast, dann spielt das da genauso eine Rolle. Man könnte sagen, wenn dein lautes Signal ist, dann überlagert das das Rauschen irgendwie besser, weil du spielst deswegen nicht so eine Rolle. Aber im Prinzip hast du das Problem immer, egal wie stark dein Signal ist an der Stelle, kann es eben passieren, dass durch ungeschickte Wandler-Fehler dann eben ein Signal entsteht, das so nie da war. Also es gibt Ansätze, dass man an der Stelle schon mit Floating Point zum Beispiel arbeitet. Haben sich allerdings nie wirklich durchgesetzt, dass man eben sagt, wenn man ein großes Signal hat, dann verschiebt man eben das Gleitkummer in die entsprechende Richtung und konzentriert sich dann eben auf den Bereich, der interessant ist.
Was heißt, hat sie nicht durchgesetzt? Das könnte ja auch noch kommen, oder?
Man müsste es in die Wandler einbauen. Das ist halt der Punkt. Die Postproduktionsketten sind eigentlich alle komplett Floating Point heutzutage. Da rechnet eigentlich keiner mehr mit Fixpoint.
Also in der Software, in der man das Audio bearbeitet etc.
Genau, es sei denn, man ist darauf angewiesen, wenn man auf irgendwelche Embedded-Devices irgendwelche herrechnet. Aber normalerweise, was moderne Computer und Schnittsoftware angeht und Plugins, so die arbeiten eigentlich alle mit Floating Point.
Klar, weil sie dann weniger Verluste haben. So, jetzt haben wir schon sehr viel geredet über die reine Wandlung. Das ist ja gerade mal so ein ganz kleiner Scope von dem, was wir heute eigentlich ansprechen wollten.
Ja, allerdings.
Haben wir denn da noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen? Ich meine, was jetzt sozusagen noch mit reinkommt, ist ja so das Timing, nicht wahr?
Genau.
Also es ist ja immer so davon ausgegangen, dass man so ganz klar weiß, wo das nächste Sample anfängt. Aber so einfach ist das nicht, oder?
Genau, also das ist das zweite große, wahrscheinlich noch größere Problem, vom Clipping mal abgesehen, ist, dass das tatsächlich, wenn wir jetzt im sehr vereinfachten Fall, irgendwie haben wir jetzt ein analogisches Signal, einen Wandler, der das irgendwie eben der 44.100 Mal pro Sekunde entscheidet. Jawohl, jetzt wäre da mal ein Sample dran und dann eben einen Messwert nimmt. In diesem sehr einfachen Fall kann man dieses Signal eben wieder nehmen und hinterher wieder ausspielen und einem Wandler vor die Füße werfen, der für sich auch irgendwie weiß, wann 44.100 Samples vorbei sind, sprich, wann eine Sekunde vergangen ist und das Material dann entsprechend wieder abspielt. An der Stelle wird schon klar, dass wenn der Wandler, der das aufgenommen hat, schneller läuft, also früher entscheidet, ein Sample zu nehmen bzw. früher entscheidet, dass eine Sekunde auf seiner eigenen Uhr eben vorbei ist, als der Wandler, der das hinterher wieder abspielt, dann wird das Audio hinten langsamer ausgegeben. Das heißt, wenn man eine Stunde aufnimmt, heißt das nicht, dass es hinterher auf dem Abspielgerät auch wieder genau eine Stunde dauert. So in der Theorie. Das ist allerdings nicht ganz so theoretisch, wenn man dann betrachtet, wie verschiedene Audiogeräte synchronisiert werden. Es ist ein ganz und gar nicht triviales Problem, zwei Soundkarten an einem Rechner zu betreiben, die für sich jeweils, weil sie einen eigenen Quarz haben, zu völlig unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten entscheiden, wann 44.100 Samples vorbei sind. Weil du einen Digitalstrom an der Stelle quasi dem einen die Geräte schneller schicken musst als dem anderen. Und zwei Clocks, die nicht synchronisiert sind, werden immer driften. Immer.
Sie müssen ja nur ein Bit daneben liegen.
Einer wird immer schneller laufen als der andere. Das ist das große Problem des Clockings. Das zieht sich durch alle Bereiche auch durch. Also ob man hier im Studio hat zum Beispiel ein digitales Effektgerät, also im Sinne von mit digitalen Ein- und Ausgängen. Dieses digitale Effektgerät muss sich natürlich nach dem Takt richten, der vorgegeben wird. Ein Gerät im digitalen Studio-Verbund muss immer der Master sein, und alle anderen haben sich danach zu halten.
Da sind diese Master-Clock-Konstellationen, da gibt es ja auch so richtig so 19 Zoll Geräte, die nichts anderes machen, als Zeit zu liefern.
Genau, weil nämlich Word-Glock-Generatoren, die zum Beispiel auch jedes größere Funkhaus hat, da gibt es dann diese Coax-Anschlüsse an jedem Schnittplatz, und da kommt der Haustakt raus. Dieser Haustakt ist das, wonach sich alle zu richten haben. Wenn man irgendwo ein Signal auf den Ether gibt, das nicht zu diesem Haustakt synchron ist, dann stürzt im Zweifel irgendwo was ab. Also diese digitalen Mischpulte, die mit digitalen Ein- und Ausgängen arbeiten, die kommen da nicht so ohne Weiteres mit klar, wenn man ihnen einfach einen völlig anderen Takt reingibt. Das ist ein großes Problem. Das heißt, alle müssen sich nach einem einzigen Takt im Netz richten.
Alle hören jetzt auf mein Kommando. Das Problem habe ich ja hier auch.
Einer, der auf der Galore vorne sitzt und auf die Trommel haut.
Allerdings habe ich das Problem nicht sehr, weil hier nahezu alles analog ist, außer dem Digitalmixer. Aber klar, in dem Moment, wo man mit ADAT und so weiter, kommen wir auch gleich noch zu, in den Schnittstellen arbeitet, dann muss halt irgendwie da auch klares Regime herrschen, wie das so ist mit der Zeit. Also Clocking ist ein Problem und ist ja auch dann in dem Moment ein Problem, wo das dann auch auf dem Rechner wieder abgespielt wird. Dann muss die Clock stimmen und wenn da sich die Komponenten auch irgendwie gegenseitig was schicken, Audio-Netzwerke.
Also es geht dann auch so weit, dass wenn man zum Beispiel eine digitale Soundkarte hat an seinem Rechner, also eine Soundkarte, die einen digitalen Input hat und an diesem digitalen Input hängt dann ein Digital-Mischpult, das den Takt vorgibt und dieses Digital-Mischpult beschließt irgendwie, jetzt ein bisschen langsamer zu laufen, hat irgendwelche Gleichlaufschwankungen und man nutzt dann auf seinem Rechner irgendwie sein iTunes, um Musik abzuspielen, dann läuft dieses iTunes auch langsamer. Muss, ja, diese Soundkarte richtet sich eben mit dem...
Also nicht das iTunes läuft langsamer, sondern das Audio läuft langsamer.
Ja, aber auch die Realzeit im iTunes vergeht dann langsamer. Also es ist nicht etwa so, dass das iTunes, jetzt ein beliebiges Beispiel eines MP3-Players, für sich entscheidet, wann eine Sekunde vorbei ist, sondern es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieser Takt, der da angezeigt wird, oder diese Realzeit, die da vergeht, die richtet sich nach der Audioclock. Was auch immer die ist. Wenn die von sonst woher kommt, dann hat dieses... Das heißt, alle Komponenten müssen auch mitspielen im gesamten Stack. Das USB-Soundkarte muss sich eben nach diesem Takt, den es von extern bekommt, richten, muss diese Geschwindigkeit in welcher Form auch immer zum Rechner propagieren und dieser Rechner muss sich dann irgendwie, also dann arbeiten dann Driver Stacks und so weiter, die sich dann eben aufsynchronisieren müssen und diese Audio-Geschwindigkeit dann eben auch benutzen, um die ganze Applikation zu clocken, intern. Also das muss ganz klar sein, wo kommt der Takt her?
Ähnliches Problem gibt es ja auch bei MIDI. Das spielt ja dann auch nochmal eine Rolle, wenn irgendwie die MIDI-Geräte sich auch alle synchronisieren müssen. Da gibt es auch entsprechende clocking-Sachen, aber das hat ja mit Audio erstmal nichts zu tun. Aber es zeigt halt einfach, Time ist halt einfach in jedem digitalen Setup und auch MIDI ist ja sozusagen ein digitales Setup, auch wenn es nicht Audio überträgt in der Regel, sondern eben Anweisungen, wann etwas zu spielen hat, aber auch die Note soll ja zum richtigen Zeitpunkt kommen, muss es sich danach richten.
Also interessant halt auch beim Broadcast zum Beispiel, wenn man sich irgendwie den Unterschied mal klarmacht zwischen analogem und digitalem Fernsehen, auch da hat man genau dieselbe Problematik. Bei analogem Fernsehen war alles sehr einfach. Da gab es einfach irgendwie ein analoges Signal, das war auf dem Ether ab einem bestimmten Frequenzband da irgendwie rein multiplex und da gab es dann FM oder AM, keine Ahnung, also im Fall von Fernsehen war es dann FM. Aber der Sender hat halt bestimmt, wie das Audiosignal auszusehen hat, und zwar immer linear komplett zu seiner Echtzeit. Und dieses Radio, dieses Fernsehgerät, hat sich entsprechend daran gerichtet, dass einfach sehr trivial zurückverwandelt von FM irgendwie auf den Lautsprecher gegeben und fertig. Bei Digitalfernsehen ist das ein riesen Problem. Weil der Sender hat natürlich eine völlig andere Glocke, zweifel- völlig andere Glocke, als mein Abspielgerät. Mein Abspielgerät hat irgendwie einen Quarz drin, der sagt halt irgendwie nach 44.100 Samples so, jo, ich werde dann jetzt eine Sekunde weiter, aber das muss überhaupt nichts damit zu tun haben.
Der Sender kann schon...
Genau, der Sender kann ja wesentlich langsamer sein. Und ich habe auch keinen Feedback-Mechanismus. Also bei einer 1 zu 1 Verbindung kann ich ja dann sagen, mach mal ein bisschen langsamer irgendwie. Ich bin noch nicht so weit. Also mein Takt läuft so ein bisschen, ist halt nicht so schnell wie deiner. Also schick mal ein bisschen langsamer. Aber im Fall von Live-Broadcasting geht das natürlich nicht. Das heißt, alle Geräte müssen entweder hergehen und dieses Material nehmen und entsprechend resamplen. Das spricht irgendwie auf die lokale Clock bringen. Oder aber sie müssen die lokale Clock nachführen. Und sagen so, der Sender ist ein bisschen schneller, dann drehen wir mal ein bisschen unter unsere eigene Geschwindigkeit mit so Tuneable Clocks und passen uns sozusagen an den Sender an. Also auch da spielt genau dieselbe Problematik eine Riesenrolle. Eines der größten Probleme an der Stelle.
Also wenn man das nicht macht, dann laufen die Dinge komplett irgendwie neben der Spur im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Die ersten Geräte dieser Art hatten auch massive Probleme damit. Da war Audio- und Videosynchronität echt nicht gut.
Das kennt man ja auch so beim Abspielen von Filmen. Also wenn man jetzt einen digitalen Film hat, aus welchen Quellen auch immer.
Da sind aber die Gründe andere. Da haben wir einen Pfeil vorliegen und dieses Pfeil, da kann man rumsiegen, das kann man uns so schnell angucken, wie wir das wollen. Wir nehmen das Material aus dem Pfeil in der Geschwindigkeit, wie unsere lokale Soundkarte arbeitet. Und wenn diese ein bisschen schneller läuft, dann läuft halt der Film ein bisschen schneller. Also an der Stelle hat die Glocke.
Okay, und diese typischen Synchronisationsprobleme zwischen Bild und Ton?
Na ja, das hat meines Erachtens eher was mit den Container-Formaten zu tun, die das irgendwie vergeigen, da ordentlich zu notieren, welche Entitäten da jetzt zusammenkommen. Aber das ist jetzt erstmal nicht das Broadcasting-Problem.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht zu sehr verwirren. Jetzt haben wir ja schon verschiedene digitale Schnittstellen auch angesprochen. Also ich meine, diese DA-Wandlung, Entschuldigung, die AD-Wandlung, also wir nehmen das adäaloge Signal, machen es digital auf Basis einer Zeiteinheit. Damit gewinnen wir dann eben jetzt konkret die Daten. Das heißt, wir haben da irgendwie Bits und Bytes und können irgendwie das abspeichern, auf Festplatte schreiben und haben das gewandelte Signal. Jetzt hat man aber meistens wenig Freude daran, das alles nur einem am Ort zu belassen, sondern man will ja auch verschiedene Komponenten miteinander verbinden und dann eben auch, wenn man einmal das schon digital hat, nicht unbedingt nochmal wandeln, weil es natürlich bei jeder Wandlung auch immer wieder schlechter wird. Das heißt, man möchte digital weiterreichen. Digitale Schnittstellen hast du ja schon angesprochen. Womit ging denn das eigentlich los? War das dann auch diese SPDIF Schnittstelle? War das so mits das Erste, was überhaupt digital kam?
Ja, also ich glaube, das weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich denke, das koaxiale SPDIF war irgendwie das Erste, was so richtig nicht nur für High-End-Studios, sondern für Konsumerbereich gedacht war. Also mit den DAT-Rekordern, glaube ich, kam das so größer auf. Und da gab es dann die ersten CD-Player, die koaxial out hatten und die ersten DAT-Rekorder, die dieses koaxiale Signal wieder entgegennehmen konnten.
Also SPDIF muss man kurz mal erläutern, heißt Sony Phillips Digital Interface und kommt halt in zwei verschiedenen Varianten. Das koaxiale oder eben diese klassischen Zinsch-Stecker, die man ja so kennt, die man auch so als analoge Audio, Ein- und Ausgänge, Konsumer-Hardware hat, Fernseher bedient und Tapes und was nicht alles. Dieser Stecker wird dann eben auch für die Übertragung eines digitalen Signals verwendet, weil es eben dahinter so ein koaxiales Kabel ist, was sich eben ganz gut eignet für die Übertragung von digitalen Werten über längere Strecken. Und das war im Prinzip einfach nur Stereo digital mit 44 oder 48, also 44.1 oder 48 Kilohertz. Ich glaube, für mehr ist das gar nicht spezifiziert gewesen.
Das Consumer SPDIF, diese Art, dass eben optisch und koaxial daherkommt, das ist tatsächlich nur für Stereo und nur für 44.1 und 48.
Und auch diese niedrige Sampling-Frequenz. Dann gibt es noch das alternative Verkabelungssystem, das man eben das Ganze mit einem optischen Kabel macht.
Was im Zweifel sinnvoller ist, weil man eine galvanische Trennung zwischen den Geräten hat und sich nicht auch noch irgendwie...
Genau, da kommt dann das sogenannte Toslink-Kabel bzw. der Toslink-Stecker, der da so quadratisch um zwei Ecken so ein bisschen angeditcht. Zum Einsatz. Das funktioniert ja an sich auch ganz gut. Das haben auch viele Computer heutzutage. Also die Soundkarten haben das. Die Macs, die Laptops haben das irgendwie mittlerweile auch. Wenn auch nicht mit diesem Toslink-Stecker, sondern eben mit so einem 3,5-Millimeter-Stecker, der dann noch ein bisschen tiefer weiter reinreit. Das ist ein bisschen schrecklich, aber...
Auch Miniklinke ist eigentlich, man soll das unter Strafe stellen, Miniklinke ist das Furchtbarste, was diese Consumer-Bed irgendwie entstand.
Ja gut, aber manchmal hat man eben nicht so viel Platz. Aber das funktioniert ja ganz gut. Zumindest hier auf Mac kann ich da nicht klagen. Man kommt da optisch gut rein und raus. Bei manchen nur raus, bei manchen eben auch rein. So, jetzt meine eigentliche Frage war, bei diesem SPDIF-Interface, das macht halt auch nur 16-Bit. Also das ist sozusagen im Prinzip so das totale Äquivalent zu dieser CD. Wie läuft denn das da mit der Zeit? Also wenn jetzt das eine Gerät mit dem anderen Gerät redet, da gibt es ja dann keinen separaten Koaxialstecker, der das Timing mit überträgt?
Nee, das wird dann in diesem Datenstrom mit übertragen. Da ist dann auch klar, weil es ja geht ja in eine Richtung so. Und wenn ich dann meine Samples schicke, ist ja auch klar, wann für mich wieder so 1100 Samples vorbei sind.
Das heißt, die Daten führen eigentlich die Clock sozusagen implizit mit sich und das ist dann am empfangenden Gerät, sich darauf zu synchronisieren, was sie dann wahrscheinlich auch in der Regel tun?
Müssen sie. Wenn sie das nicht tun, knallt es.
Also das ist ganz klar. Knallt im Sinne von...
Naja, es gibt halt Glitches und das hört sich nicht gut an.
Klingt dann halt scheiße.
Und das große Problem ist, wenn du ein Gerät entwickeln willst, dass es mehrere digitale Inputs hat. Das geht eigentlich nicht ohne, dass man jedes einzelne resample und auf eine gemeinsame Glocke bringt. Auch durch diese Mythos der digitalen Funkmikrofone. Mir ist überhaupt nicht klar, wie die das machen. Außer halt, dass sie komplett resample müssen. Alle denken, das ist geil, da habe ich direkt im Mikro schon meinen AD-Wandler und gehe dann direkt komplett digital die ganze Strecke. Aber das ist Unfug. Es sei denn, du brauchst nur ein Mikrofon.
Resample, sagen wir noch mal kurz erläutern. Wenn man das Problem hat, dass die Zeit auseinanderläuft, dann muss ich ja irgendwie das wieder reinkriegen. Wenn man zum Beispiel vorstellt, ich habe Gerät A und Gerät B und jeder ist jetzt mit jedem mit so einer SPDIF-Verbindung verbunden. Der eine schickt dem einen, der andere dem anderen. Jeder hat so implizit die Glocke, das kann ja dann gar nicht funktionieren.
Was das Resampling an der Stelle tut, im Prinzip kann man sich vorstellen, es ist fast so schlimm, wie einmal zurückzuwandeln nach analog und dann wieder nach digital, und dass diese analoge Stufe in der Mitte nicht existiert. Aber es wird halt angeschaut, es wird das eingehende Signal interpoliert im Sinne von massiven Oversampling, was wir vorhin hatten, und dann wird eben mit der Abtastfrequenz der Master-Clock wieder geschaut, wo steht das Signal. Dass es dadurch nicht besser werden kann, ist, glaube ich, klar. Deswegen ist Resampling...
Will man vermeiden.
Man will es wirklich vermeiden.
Und man kann es aber eigentlich nur dann vermeiden, wenn man eben eine klare Clocking-Schrucht verweist.
Genau, was bei digitalen Funk-Mikrofonen nicht funktioniert, es sei denn, man broadcastet den Master-Takt. Was sie aber nicht tun. Ich habe extra ein paar Hersteller gefragt, und das tun sie nicht.
Ach so, das ist das Problem, dass man sozusagen keine Klassen kann.
Na ja, wie soll das Mikrofon sonst wissen, wann 44.100 Samples vorbei sind? Kann es ja nicht wissen. Es muss seinen eigenen Takt haben, und den broadcastet es eben auf den Adder. Und die Gegenseite kann gucken, wie sie damit klarkommt.
Na gut, aber es ist dann genauso wie beim normalen SPD-Verbindung. Also man synkt dann sich sozusagen auf das Mikrofon ein.
Richtig, wenn du nur ein Mikrofon hast, dann geht das. Aber in der Regel, also diese Mikrofone, die ich meine, sind halt irgendwie für Live-Acts gedacht. Und da hast du natürlich weit mehr als ein Mikrofon. Und jedes kommt mit seinen eigenen 44.100 Samples halt daher. Also nicht, dass es nicht funktionieren kann, aber diese Hype ist meines Erachtens völliger Blödsinn, weil das nicht besser werden kann dadurch. Also vielleicht fehlt mir da auch Wissen. Nur zu, aber meines Erachtens ist das Quatsch.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem. Ich meine, digital an der Stelle bei Funk macht natürlich auch Sinn, weil man natürlich theoretisch Fehler, Korrektur und weniger Schwankung jetzt von dem eigentlichen Funk-Signal hat. So Rauschen, also das, was halt gemeinhin immer so als der Vorteil von Digital Audio konfrontiert wird und was ja jetzt auch nicht ganz falsch ist.
Ja, also keine Ahnung. Also muss ich mal angucken, was aus diesem Digital Fernsehen was das so für akute Probleme mit sich bringt. Dann ist es halt kein harmonisches Rauschen mehr, dass man sich auch noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dass man noch verschmerzen kann, sondern es gibt halt sofort enorme Artefakte und Glötzchen im Bild und so weiter. Ein wirklicher Gewinn ist das an der Stelle nicht.
Also du meinst, wenn Fehler dann richtig?
Ja, dann ist halt gleich alles am Arsch.
Was Digitalfernsehen ja auch total zerstört ist ja das gemeinsame Erleben. Ich erinnere mich immer noch an die Weltmeisterschaft.
Die sind dann irgendwie aus verschiedenen Häusern, fünf Sekunden früher irgendwie.
Genau, da hast du gehört, die Kabelfernsehen-Jungs, die haben irgendwie so zuerst geschrien. Und dann kamen dann die DVBT-Leute, durften zwei Sekunden später jubeln. Und dann, drei Sekunden später, haben sie doch noch mit dem Satellitenempfang irgendwie auch gehört.
Ja, dann kommt es darauf an, mit welcher Software du da irgendwie arbeitest. Weil, wenn die da aus Angst irgendwelche, bis die Kunden einen langen Chitterbuffer einbauen, dann...
Da sind wir dann bei der Latenz, aber...
Genau, da kommen wir später gleich nochmal drauf. Vielleicht sollten wir diese Interfaces nochmal abstimmen.
Genau.
Da gibt es ja auch wirklich eine Menge.
Genau, was gibt es denn da sonst noch so? Also, das SPDiff ist sicherlich das bekannteste. Da hat jeder irgendwo ein Gerät, was das macht. Aber was es halt schwierig macht, ist, dass es eben zwei Kabelstandards gibt. Mal hast du ein Gerät, das es irgendwie nur mit Coax macht. Mal hast du eins, das macht nur optisch. Welchen hat man mal eins, was beides macht. Das ist total nervig.
Was sie auch haben, das hat der Rekord noch erwähnt, sind diese sogenannten User-Bits. Die kodieren sie dann auch noch parallel zu dem Audiostrom mit rein.
Ach, da ist ja noch so eine Copy-Beschränkung drin.
Richtig, da kannst du dann sagen, irgendwie dieses Material, da ist nur ein Hörner, der will nicht wegschreiben. Dann kann die Gegenseite, wenn sie auch so politisch korrekt ist, dann auch sagen, so nö, da kannst du jetzt nicht auf Record drücken.
Damit hat sich Dat seinerzeit komplett selbst ermordet.
Tatsächlich, ja. Jo, dann gibt es das Äquivalent zum SPDIF. Im Profibereich ist das AES IBU. Das steht für, bis vorhin haben wir nachgeholt, Audio Engineering Society European Broadcast Union.
Ja, die machen die Standards, ne?
Ja, genau.
Also genau genommen ist das ja eigentlich gar nicht der Bezeichnung.
Das ist nicht der Bezeichnung des Standards. Der Standard heißt eigentlich AES III. Aber man spricht in der Regel von AES IBU als das Transportmittel für Digital Audio. Das funktioniert dann über XLR-Kabel. Da hat man dann schon mal irgendwie Masse und zwei Leitungen, wenn man das Signal symmetrisch überträgt, was dann natürlich im Zweifel Störungen hat eliminiert. Wenn Störungen auf beide gleichzeitig wirken, dann kann man das hinterher wieder rausrechnen. Deswegen kommen die auch auf ein paar hundert Meter, können die damit übertragen.
Und was macht das so für Taktraten, Samplingraten, Wortbreiten?
Das geht soweit ich weiß weiter. Ich glaube, die können bis 96 oder 192 ich weiß gerade gar nicht ganz genau.
32, 44, 1, 48, 96 sind üblich. Und hier und da 88, 2 und 192. Das ist alles möglich. Und 16 und 24 Bit. Und das ist eigentlich so das, was man so im Profibereich verwendet. Also pro Kabel. Zwei Kanäle.
Und es hat einen höheren Hub. Also ich glaube, dieses SPDIF-Koaxial ist irgendwie so ein halbes Volt oder so. Bisschen wackelig. Reicht irgendwie vom CD-Blayer zum DAT gerade so. Aber das AES-EBU ist halt mehr so für den für den harten Live-Einsatz auch gedacht gewesen. Wobei da irgendwie halt Stereo ist ein bisschen wenig. Deswegen gibt es diesen nächsten Standard, der heißt sich MADi.
Wie läuft denn das denn da mit der Clock? Also eigentlich genauso wie bei SPDIF. Da ist halt einfach, Clock ist einfach implizit und muss man sich separat nochmal drum kümmern. Genau.
Also es ist letztlich halt die Aufgabe des Empfängers, daraus halt dann das Beste zu machen. Wenn es nur einen Input gibt, dann ist der halt der Master im Zweifel. Wenn es mehrere gibt, muss man sich etwas einfallen lassen. Dann gibt es MADI, das sie sich auch AIS-10 nennt. Und die können dann deutlich mehr.
Das ist so, was man mit so dicken, fetten Mischpulten vorfindet, oder?
Richtig. Wenn man mal guckt, so Live-Konzerte irgendwas, die sie so verwenden, dann ist das entweder so ein analoges Multicore, das sie von der Bühne zum Mischpult werfen oder sie haben eben ihre gesamte analog-digital-Mantelung schon auf der Bühne und transportieren dann, also da ist dann auch das Glockenproblem erstmal nicht da, weil man hat dann quasi einen Takt, der dort auf der Bühne erzeugt wird und schmeißt dann das Mischpult entsprechend zu mit bis zu 64 Kanälen Audio bei 48 KHz. Und ich glaube, sie kommen hoch bis 96, aber dann mit weniger Kanälen.
Das heißt, da kann man über ein Kabel verschiedene Kanäle machen. Was passt da so drauf? 28.
Ja, wenn man höhere Sampling-Frequenzen... Das nächste 90 Kilo sind 28 steht hier, genau. Und wenn man mit weniger auskommt, 48 KHz, das sind die Nominalfrequenzen, dann passen da 64 drauf. Das wird auch eingesetzt, das findet man im Live-Bereich sehr viel. Also große Soundmischpulte haben dann entsprechend eine tiefe Unterstützung für Mahdi direkt.
Das findet man aber wirklich nur für solche PA-Bereiche, wo man wirklich so einen hohen Kanalbedarf hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob auch größere Studios. Die auch in der Lage sind, ganze Orchester zu recorden.
Also mein Mixer hat das nicht.
Dein Mixer hat...
Das ist Fremdtechnologie. Mein Mixer hat dafür was anderes.
Ich finde, eine ganz andere Technik.
Hier ist noch ADAT mit drin. Das ist natürlich auch noch sehr hübsch. Also ADAT ist von der Firma Al-Dezis mal entwickelt worden. Da kommt dann immer wieder die Zahl 8 hoch. Das ist früher so ein bisschen das Multitrack-Ideal gewesen. Vier- und achtspuren Recorder. Da kriegt man schon so eine kleine Band mit drauf. Der Sänger, die Gitarre, das Schlagzeug, keine Ahnung.
Das muss man halt bouncen. Man mikrofoniert das Schlagzeug mit acht Mikrofonen. Dann macht man sich daraus einen Stereomix und den spielst du einmal aus, spielst ihn zurück. Dann hat man wieder sechs Spuren frei und kann den Rest irgendwie... Egal. Aber acht war schon besser als zwei. Deswegen hat der Alices da einen enormen Erfolg mit.
Dieses ADAT-Interface ist nämlich auch heute noch erfreulich vielen Geräten zu finden. Man kann dann eben die vorhin schon angesprochenen TOS-Link optischen Kabel dafür verwenden. Optisch auch gleich wieder den Vorteil, dass man keine Potentialprobleme hat. Und auch schön lange Strecken damit machen kann und eben auch acht Kanäle darüber bekommt. Das ist schon wirklich echt super. Genau, das kann man auch mit 96 Kilohertz machen. Das ist entsprechend weniger. Also mehr Luft hat das dann irgendwie nicht. Aber es ist halt einfach überaus praktisch, wenn man eben mal mehr als sowieso macht. Also ich habe jetzt hier in dem Sinne bei meinem Mischpult gar keine weitere Verwendung dafür, außer dass ich da halt noch ein Gerät angeschlossen habe, was mir aus diesen acht Kanälen dann einfach noch mal analog rein rausmacht. Das heißt, ich verwende das einfach, um noch mal mehr Eingänge und Ausgänge zu haben.
Steckt kein einziges Kabel drin?
Heute steckt da kein Kabel drin, aber das war bei der Synthesizer-Sendung definitiv anders. Da stecken da so einige Kabel drin. Dafür ist halt im Wesentlichen eigentlich auch gedacht, dass man mal so eben ambulant da reinballern könnte. Was ich ganz gerne hätte, wäre mal so ein Gerät, was so 4 SPDIF Ein- und Ausgänge auf ADAT umsetzt. Sowas fände ich mal ganz toll. Aber da sind wir natürlich genau bei diesem Problem mit diesem Sampling.
Genau, wo kommt die Glocke her? Das ist das große Dilemma.
Genau, was weiß ich, um so Computer anzuschließen. Naja, das ist so mein Spezialbedarf.
Also dieses ADAT konnte sogar höhere Samplingfrequenzen sogar noch, wenn man entsprechend Kanäle zusammengefasst hat. Das ging auch.
Also dann 690.
Ich hab das nicht verwendet, aber ja, genau. Wenn man es einfach zwei zusammen nimmt, dann kann man mit einer doppelten Abtastfrequenz arbeiten.
Genau.
Ist allerdings komplett incompatibel zur SPDIF. Also hat, spricht auf dem untersten Encoding-Level, was völlig anderes. Deswegen kriegt man die beiden Welten auch so ohne Weiteres nicht verheiratet. Das sei denn, man geht wirklich hier und zerlegt das, was da drin steckt und bastelt daraus dann wieder SPDIF.
Aber es gibt Geräte, die das ja wohl können. Ich habe hier noch so ein anderes Teil da in meinem Rack. Dann haben die da aber ein Mototeil, das kann halt jeden Port entweder als ADAT oder als SPDIF betreiben.
Okay, dann schalten die da um intern. Aber erst mal vom Protokoll her sind die inkopatibel.
Das ist nämlich auch meine Frage gewesen, ob das nämlich jetzt so Laptops, die so einen SPDIF-Port haben, ob die da nicht ohne weiteres eigentlich auch ADAT drüber machen können müssten.
Der Link-Layer ist ja derselbe. Insofern, oder glaube ich zumindest, also ich meine, eine 1 oder eine 0 wird quasi irgendwie auf dem Fiber-Optik-Cable erst mal gleich übertragen. Aber was dann eben danach passiert, welche Form der digitalen Encodierung dann da stattfindet, das ist dann unterschiedlich. Und ich bin nicht sicher, was die da verbaut haben in diesen MacBooks oder wo auch immer es drin steckt. Und je nachdem, wenn dieser Baustein, der halt ultra-lowcost dann irgendwie hergestellt wird, halt nur SPDIF macht, dann ist das so. Und ich gehe eigentlich davon aus, dass das so ist.
Und im Software könnte man das nicht reißen?
Ne, also soweit ich weiß, ist das dann einfach eine Limitierung dieses Bausteins, der dann irgendwie, weil du machst so mit Big-Sälen, mit der Treiber-Software nicht jedes Bit dann zurecht, sondern überlässt natürlich irgendwie das eigentliche Enkodieren für das optische Signal natürlich ein Baustein, der das irgendwie...
Das ist echt super schade, das habe ich mir nicht verstanden, warum man das nicht einfach mal reinbaut.
Das stimmt politische Gründe auch.
Ja, das wäre besonders unangenehm, aber ich meine, so eine kleine 3,5 Millimeter-Buchse und dann acht Kanäle rein, raus, das wäre doch mal wirklich der Klopper. Naja, keiner hört auf den Musiker. Schlimm, oder? Dann gibt es hier noch so T-Diff von Tascam, das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen so was Ähnliches wie Adat, aber hat nicht ganz so viel Popularität erworben. Ich habe hier ja was anderes Schickes, da kann ich ja mal ein bisschen erzählen. Mein Mischpult macht das jetzt mit Ethernet, das ist ja so der neue Trend, dass man eben Digital Audio auch über Ethernet verbreitet. Macht ja auch total Sinn, weil man dann natürlich entweder sogar schon bestehende Infrastrukturen einfach so mitverwenden kann, bzw. auch komplexe Setups eben einfach mit so Ethernet-Switch-Technologie aufbauen kann und dann eben den ganzen Vorteil, den man eben so hat durch flexible Topologien und eben gute Verbreitung und CAD5-Kabel kriegt man halt auch mal eben so geschmissen und man kriegt ja vor allem bei Gigabit Ethernet dann auch gleich wirklich so hunderte von Kanälen übertragen. Das ist so alles so ein bisschen auf dem Weg der Standardisierung.
Es skaliert halt, ja, das ist schon richtig.
Da sind diese AVB-Standards am Kommen und du meintest vorhin, also das dauert nicht mehr lange, ich weiß nicht, ich bin so von ein, zwei Jahren ausgegangen, bis dann wirklich mal so Produkte konkret auf Basis dieser Standards dann am Start sind.
Ich habe es nicht genau verstanden, es gibt da wohl mehrere Schichten in diesem Standard. Ich habe schon tatsächlich funktionierende Prototypen gesehen in Hardware, die dieses AVB sprechen, die sich auch unterhalten darüber. Und das hat aber halt viele Aspekte, soweit ich das verstanden habe. Ich muss mir das nochmal genauer angucken, aber das geht ja dann auch bis zum Clocking. Also natürlich geht das halt auch vor allem um Clocking. Das war das große Problem.
Der Clocking-Teil ist meines Wissens der gelöste. Ja, aber auch der gelöste Teil. Sonst würde ja überhaupt nichts drum laufen. Aber kabeln sie sich, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen noch so um, wie denn die Switches so mit Bufferingen und so weiter umgehen müssen. Im Prinzip genau diese Resampling-Problematik hat man natürlich in dem Moment, wo so ein Switch-Paket auf dem einen Port annimmt und auf dem anderen weiter reichen soll, ein Realtime, hat man natürlich auch.
Klar, vor allem musst du auch die Latenz wissen. Das ist auch das Komplizierte. Du willst halt nicht nur, dass die alle synchron sind, sondern du willst eigentlich auch wissen, wie groß ist denn die Latenz bis dahin. Genau, nur so kriegst du dann halt irgendwie ein Beamer-Bild zu deiner Stereo-Einlage synchron. Wenn du es nicht weißt, dann musst du so lange im VLC Plus und Minus drücken, damit es irgendwie passt.
Also derzeit gibt es im Markt so zwei verbreitete Systeme, nämlich EtherSound und CobraNet, die aber beide so im Wesentlichen das Ethernet so für sich komplett beanspruchen, also die Bindepress war Ethernet, aber vor allem kann da eben auch nichts anderes drauf laufen, d.h. das ist quasi nur ein anderes Audio-Kabel. Was ich aber jetzt hier drin habe, ist diese Ordinate-Karte, die ist ganz großartig in diesem Mixer drin und das macht halt Gigabit Ethernet aber eben co-existierend so richtig mit IP. Das Ding schaltet man ein, dann setze ich mit DRCP eine IP-Adresse und ist irgendwie ein Good Citizen und dann gibt es dann irgendwie auch noch entsprechende Software auf dem Rechner, die sich dann eben auch noch so verhält wie so ein Gerät und das basiert auch alles schon auf diesen AVB-Standard, so wie sie sich abzeichnen bzw. auf dem...
Die Idee ist ähnlich.
Nee, es ist auch tatsächlich dieselben Protokolle. Und da ändern sich dann eigentlich jetzt nur noch so ein paar Daten, Strom, Details, die sie dann gedenken auch anzupassen, wenn das dann sozusagen mal alles verabschiedet ist. Aber die Grundlage ist dieses IEEE 1588. Ich hoffe, ich habe das jetzt richtig wiedergegeben. Das ist halt so ein Real-Time-Clock-Protokoll, was eben ja alles synchronisiert und was auch ganz pfiffig ist, weil wenn da irgendwie mal die Master-Clock dann ausfällt, dann einigen die sich auch gleich, wer jetzt die Master-Clock ist und so. Das ist richtig geile Scheiße.
Ja, hoffen, dass es sich durchsetzt und dass das halt auch dazu führt, dass man irgendwie halt verschiedene Komponenten auch zusammenbringen kann, die jetzt erstmal vielleicht in direkter Konkurrenz auch zueinander stehen.
Also bei mir funktioniert das super.
Ja, du hast ja aber auch nur ein Gerät und einen Computer. Also ich sage nur, also wenn er...
Aber soweit funktioniert das schon mal super. Das konnte ich jetzt über meinen FireWire und USB-Schnittstellen irgendwie nicht sagen.
Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal mehr so auf diese Computerwelt. Ich hätte noch ganz kurz zwei Protokolle, die vielleicht Erwähnung finden sollten, die jetzt nicht sich präsentieren in irgendwas, was der User zu Hause irgendwie selber verstöpseln kann, sondern die eine Rolle spielen im elektronischen Design von Schaltungen. Und da gibt es im Wesentlichen zwei Dinge, die man deren Namen kurz sagen sollte. Eine ist AC97, kennt wahrscheinlich der eine oder andere aus dem...
AC97?...
aus dem Windows Geräte-Manager, das Ding mit dem Fragezeichen davon. AC97 ist eben ein Standard, der von vielen Codex gesprochen wird, also Codex im Sinne von kleinen Hardware-Bausteinen, die eben Audio-Input und Output regeln und ganz gerne auf Mainboards verbaut sind. Da gibt es eben gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu erzählen, außer dass man theoretisch bis zu 12 Kanälen übertragen kann. Und sich deshalb das Ganze auch eignet für mehr Kanaltonen, also 5.1, 7.1.
Also das heißt, wenn man jetzt seine eigene Hardware zusammenbastelt, dann wäre das sozusagen ein Stein, den man nehmen kann?
Es ist auch ein Standard, der eben auf dem Low-Level-Bereich implementiert wird von Herstellern von Mainboards usw.
Und der Standard deckt sozusagen auch das vollständige Protokoll zwischen zwei Komponenten ab?
Genau. Das sind irgendwie fünf Leitungen, mit denen der Master mit dem Slave verknippert wird. Und dann können da bis zu zwölf Kanälen tatsächlich übertragen werden, theoretisch. Was anderes ist I2S. Das ist ein reiner Stereo-Codec. Da kann man zwei Kanäle pro I2S-Bus verbauen, aber dafür kann man bis zu 192 KHz 32 Bit tatsächlich an Daten schieben. Wird auch viel verwendet in so embedded Geräten. Auf dem untersten Level quasi die Verbindung von einem Audio-Codec zu dem nächsten Shatterbit.
DA-Wandler oder AD-Wandler?
Nein, ein Codec ist ein DA- und AD-Wandler in einem Paket. Die Verbindung von diesem Codec zum nächsten System paart, der sich dafür interessiert. Im Zweifel dann irgendein embedded Controller oder so was. Da ist I2S eben auch verwendet.
Bei diesem ganzen Hin und Her mit den Clocks und so, wir haben es ja schon angesprochen, kommt immer wieder diese Latenz mit rein. Das ist ja ein richtiger Fluch.
Ja, mit Glocking erstmal, aber so nicht unbedingt was zu tun.
Aber mit der Wandlung hat es zu tun. Das dauert ja auch alles irgendwie.
Ja, also eine typische AD-Wandlung dauert irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, so eine halbe Millisekunde oder so was in der Größenordnung. Also bis dann wirklich aus einem analogen Signal ein digitales geworden ist, das ist gar nicht so sehr das Problem.
Eine halbe Millisekunde. Das ist aber schon eine Menge Zeit eigentlich.
Ja, naja, also man muss bei der ganzen Latenz-Betrachtung immer so ein bisschen auch die Schallgeschwindigkeit im Blick haben, wenn man überlegt, der Schall ist so 340 Meter pro Sekunde etwa. Das heißt, in einer hundertstel Sekunde liegt der 3,4 Meter zurück. Das heißt, ich habe halt schon bei 3 Meter Abstand zu meiner Soundquelle automatisch 10 Millisekunden Latenz. Das ist halt auch nicht gerade wenig. Also irgendwann spielt bei der Betrachtung natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Frage, wie weit sitze ich von meinen Boxen weg? Also wenn man sich über eine halbe Millisekunde hin oder her dann irgendwie streitet, dann ist das halt auch schon entscheidend.
Schwierig wird es natürlich immer dann, wenn man seine eigene Stimme hört, weil da ist natürlich der Abstand sehr gering. Mein Ohr und mein Mund sind relativ nah beieinander, also noch näher als das Hirn manchmal. Aber man hört sich ja sozusagen wirklich in totaler Echtzeit. Und wenn man halt jetzt so ein Kontrollsignal einspielt, wie wir das jetzt hier auch gerade machen, weil wir hier mit Headsets, also mit Kopfhörer aufnehmen und das gemixte Signal eben auch hören, da spielt halt jede Millisekunde schon eine Rolle. Und ich war vor ein paar Tagen, Wochen, war ich hier in so einem Sonderbereich des Technikmuseums in Berlin. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, das ist mehr so für Kinder eigentlich so gedacht. Da gibt es dann verschiedene, so physikalische Grundlagenerklärungen, quasi so als ganz einfache Hands-on-Erklärungen, was weiß ich, so Strom und irgendwie Blitz und alles Mögliche, Optik und eben auch Akustik. Und dann gab es eben ein ganz interessantes Setup. Da waren dann so zwei Lautsprecher an so einem Computer angeschlossen. Man konnte also seinen Kopf da irgendwie reinhalten, also quasi wie einen Kopfhörer aufsetzen. Und dort wurde eben genau diese Latenz erklärt mit der Aussage, dass ein Mensch eine Latenz unter drei Millisekunden in der Regel nicht mehr so sehr wahrnimmt. Also das war sozusagen die Behauptung, dass man eben ab drei Sekunden es nicht mehr merkt.
Drei Millisekunden.
Drei Millisekunden. Und das Setup an der Stelle war, dass eben links und rechts ein Kopfhörer oder ein Lautsprecher einfach in Knacken eingespielt wurde und man konnte dann auf dem Computer die Latenz einstellen, mit der eben dieses Knacken abgespielt wurde. Dann konnte man halt so runtergehen von 20, 10 und so weiter, immer eine Millisekunde weniger. Und ich sagte dir, ich habe auch noch eine Millisekunde gehört. Also ich konnte einen Links-Rechts-Unterschied wahrnehmen. Also vielleicht ist das nur ein Bild.
Und das war links-rechts verzögert?
Na, du konntest halt einstellen, ob das Knacken im linken Ohr...
Also nicht zwei auf beiden Ohren, sondern links-rechts hat sich verschoben zueinander. Genau.
Du hast halt ein Links- und ein Rechtsknacken gehabt. Und du konntest eben einstellen, in welchem Abstand dieses Knacken stattfand. Und bei vier, fünf Millisekunden war das einfach ganz, ganz, ganz deutlich. Aber ich konnte halt auch noch den Unterschied mit einer Millisekunde hören.
Jaja, das ist aber nochmal ein anderes Thema. Das ist, warum wir Stereo hören. Also Stereo hören hat weniger damit zu tun, dass ein Signal, also wenn jetzt ein Signal von links kommt zum Beispiel, und du die Augen zumachst, kannst du sagen, es kommt von links. Das liegt aber weniger daran, dass das Signal an deinem linken Ohr lauter ankommt, als an deinem rechten. Denn je nach Frequenz beugt sich das Signal auch einfach um deinen Kopf rum, als wäre er nicht da sozusagen. Sondern es hat viel mehr damit zu tun, dass das Signal links zuerst ankommt und dann erst rechts. Und das sind natürlich irgendwie, wenn man sich die beiden Ohren, keine Ahnung, Abstand von 20 Zentimetern, anschaut, natürlich irgendwie keine besonders großen Laufzeiten, die dann das Hirn aber in der Lage sein muss, zu verarbeiten. Und deswegen hört man das da dann schon eher, wenn es um links-rechts-Synchronität geht. Das ist auch das große Problem, warum Stereo-Lautsprecher, die digital angefahren werden, in der Regel immer analog synchronisiert werden. Also es gibt, weiß nicht, auf so Consumer-Messen sieht man es ab und zu, so Funk-Lautsprecher, die links und rechts neben der Stereo-Anlage stehen und jeweils eine eigene Antenne haben oder halt keine Ahnung, mit irgendwas Digitalem angefahren werden. Und wenn die ihre eigene Glocke erzeugen müssen und zudem noch nicht genau wissen, wo der andere Lautsprecher eigentlich gerade ist, dann driften die, wie gesagt, die großen Glocke in Problematik. Und dieses Driften ist sehr viel unangenehmer, als wenn beide gleichzeitig im Takt schwanken würden. Deshalb, weil sich eben das komplette Stereo-Bild verschiebt.
Ah ja, verstehe.
Also wenn, auch in der Reproduktion des Klang-Signals spielt natürlich dann auch wieder genau dasselbe Ding eine Rolle.
Kommen wir weg von meiner Kopfhörer-Fixiertheit und meinem speziellen Latenzproblem. So oder so will man aber immer eine möglichst niedrige Latenz haben. Weil sich das natürlich auch alles summiert. Weil eine Verzögerung, die einmal irgendwo in irgendeiner Kette entstanden ist, die kriegt man auch nicht wieder eingefangen.
Die Frage, ob man es muss, ganz kurz noch erwähnt, also das Ding ist schon, wenn man zum Beispiel Klavier spielt und hat jetzt Kopfhörer auf und jeder Synthesizer, den man da verwendet, hat jetzt eine gewisse Latenz, dann ist das Hirn durchaus in der Lage, so eine Latenz auszugleichen. Beim Schlagzeug zum Beispiel holt man auch mit den Sticks wesentlich früher aus, bevor man irgendwie den Klang erzeugen will. Das heißt, das Hirn arbeitet irgendwie permanent asynchron zu dem, was eigentlich passiert. Und deswegen kann das Hirn auch in die Lage versetzt werden, so eine Latenz zu ignorieren, sich daran zu gewöhnen. Speziell bei so Instrumenten ist das möglich.
Aber bei der Stimme ist es schwieriger.
Jaja, klar. Das ist ein Unterschied da. Aber generell natürlich, wenn man es trotz allem so gering wie möglich hat.
Gut, aber immer eine Frage ist jetzt eigentlich, wodurch entsteht die Latenz bei der Wandlung? Weil man muss ja, hatten wir ja am Anfang schon, hätten wir im Prinzip auch gleich am Anfang darauf eingehen können, wenn ich halt jetzt so wandle, muss ich ja mir irgendwie dieses Signal anschauen und dadurch entstehen, da muss man dann irgendwie buffern, da muss man dann irgendwie abwarten oder also was erzeugt diese Verzögerung?
Es gibt verschiedene Details, die dann halt eine Rolle spielen. Der Wandler selber ist es in der Regel wie gesagt nicht unbedingt. Der Wandler selber hat irgendwie keine Ahnung, Bruchteil von einer Millisekunde nur, die er braucht, um wirklich ein Signal zu erzeugen. Aber dann muss das Signal dann doch irgendwie halt zum Rechner kommen und muss dann dort verarbeitet werden und muss dann halt auch den kompletten Weg dann zurücknehmen. Jetzt machen wir mal ein einfaches Beispiel. Du hast irgendwie einen Plug-In, das rechnet einen Hall auf irgendwas drauf. Und du hast ein Eingangssignal von deinem Mikrofon. Und das muss also gewandelt werden zum Rechner. Dort muss das Processing stattfinden. Und dann muss es zurück auf deinen DA-Wandler und damit auf deinen Kopfhörer. Die meiste Zeit vergeht dabei bei der Verarbeitung im Computer tatsächlich. Also du brauchst natürlich, je nachdem, wie das Audio da transportiert wird, irgendwie bei Ethernet brauchst du natürlich eine gewisse Mindestpaketgröße, die halt erstmal voll werden muss, bevor das Paket auf die Reise geht. Bei USB und FireWire ist es im Prinzip das gleiche Problem. Und dann muss ich eben deine Software darum kümmern. Und je größer die Pakete sind, die eine Software, ein Effektgerät, wie auch immer, verarbeiten muss, desto weniger oft muss quasi ein Context Switch in deinem System stattfinden und desto performanter wird das mit der Software.
Das heißt, umso niedriger die Latenz, umso mehr CBO-Bedarf hat man sozusagen.
Ja, damit hängt das zusammen. Und ab einem gewissen Punkt geht es halt nicht mehr. Wenn die Pakete winzig klein werden und die Software sich dann daran ständig für jede 96 Samples dann irgendwie neu kümmern muss, dann ist dann eine gewisse natürliche Grenze irgendwann erreicht.
Aber wenn das Problem nur das Füllen von Paketen ist, könnte man sich ja dadurch helfen, dass man einfach mehr Samples nimmt, dass man die Samplingrate erhöht. Dann fallen ja mehr Daten an.
Ja, dann muss deine Software aber natürlich mit mehr Samples arbeiten. Das macht es dann auch nicht wieder schneller. Im Prinzip stimmt das aber, ja. Das ist richtig.
Also man hat mehr Daten und damit muss man auch klarkommen, aber man kann zumindest schon mal die Pakete folgen.
Genau, je nachdem, was das eben für ein System ist. Aber klar, wenn das maßgebliche Element, das Silenzen erzeugt, irgendwie ein Jitter-Buffer ist, der voll werden muss, dann kann man das durch höhere Samplingraten tatsächlich verschieben, das Problem. Allerdings hast du dann natürlich im Zweifel, keine Ahnung, bei einer PCI-Karte dann halt irgendwie mehr Interrupts, die ausgelöst werden, jenes Mal, wenn ein Buffer voll ist. Das heißt, du hast an der Stelle wieder eine höhere Belastung des Betriebssystems. Der Treiber muss öfter aufgerufen werden, um sich zu kümmern, die Daten zu verschaufeln und so weiter. Ja, an der Stelle, keine Ahnung, wir sollten auf jeden Fall auch noch irgendwie die Treibermodelle uns anschauen.
Da wollte ich jetzt im Prinzip ja auch gerade hin. Also ich meine, bei Audio-Interfaces, die man heutzutage so bekommt, die so real existieren, da sind die meisten halt USB-basiert mittlerweile. Ein gutes Stück benutzt FireWire als Interfaces. Solche externen Busse machen ja auch sehr gut Sinn, weil es ja nochmal eine besondere Herausforderung ist, so diese DA-Wandlung, Entschuldigung, die AD-Wandlung vor allem, direkt im Rechner zu machen. Man könnte ja sagen, na okay, dann nimmt man halt so eine Karte. Bei PCs hat man ja in der Regel immer Slots, bei Macs eben nur, wenn man jetzt so eine dicke Maschine kauft oder noch einen alten Laptop hat, wo man eben so eine Karte reinstecken kann. Da wäre man dann sozusagen direkt auf dem Computerbus und schon genau da, wo man es eigentlich hinhaben will. Von daher müsste man sich eben nicht noch auf vergleichsweise langsame Busse einlassen. Aber die haben natürlich auch den Vorteil, dass sie erstmal eine Raumtrennung machen, weil so ein Computer ist natürlich die totale Audio-Hölle mit seinen ganzen Quarzen und Störsignalen. Das brummt und sort, jeder der mal einfach nur einen Laptop irgendwie...
Ja, mal ordentlich aufdrehen und mit der Maus rumfuchteln, irgendwie, dann hört man so alle...
Wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, es ist ganz furchtbar.
Genau, deswegen macht das schon Sinn, das extern zu haben. Also FireWire macht das ja im Prinzip, bringt ja quasi den Systembus auch nur nach außen. Also da hat man ja auch vollen Zugriff auf den Speicher. Insofern hat man bei der USB-Sendung, glaube ich, auch kurz erwähnt.
Haben wir da auch über FireWire geredet? Ganz kurz, okay, gut.
Der große prinzipielle Unterschied an der Stelle ist, dass FireWire in der Lage ist, direkt in meinen Systemrahmen zu schreiben. Genau, was sich natürlich auch super zum Kompromittieren von Systemen hernehmen lässt und was ein riesen Problem ist an der Stelle. Aber für Audio und Video kommt einem das natürlich sehr zugute, weil der Rechner gar nicht mitkriegt, dass sich da der Buffer füllt. Da wird überhaupt niemand darüber informiert. Nur wenn sich der Buffer einmal gefüllt hat, dann gibt es noch, keine Ahnung, kann man sich eben ein Signal geben lassen und dann eben die Daten erst angucken. Bei USB muss halt wirklich jedes einzelne Paket vom Haus initiiert werden, bequeued werden und so weiter. Und das ist natürlich ein höherer Aufwand. Und deswegen ist auch die Latenz höher. Das ist schon auch der Grund.
Grundsätzlich?
Bei USB ja, im Prinzip. Also mit steigenden Rechnergeschwindigkeiten und so weiter spielt das immer weniger eine Rolle. Ja, aber das Prinzipproblem bleibt. Das Paket muss halt wirklich angefasst werden und dann müssen die Daten da raus kopiert werden, demultiplexed im Zweifel, keine Ahnung. Während das bei FireWire kann man halt einfach munter drauf losballern. Wo wir bei USB sind, da gibt es halt auch, wie in der USB-Sendung damals schon erwähnt, ein Klassenmodell für Audio.
Also im Reihen des USB-Standards.
Genau, das USB-Konsortium hat sich eben Gedanken gemacht, wie bilden wir Audio-Devices eben in Klassendeskriptoren ab? Und hat dann so ein Set von Standards released. Und da steht eben drin, wenn ein USB-Gerät sich anmeldet, dann kann es von sich behaupten, ein Audio-Device zu sein. Und dann gehören folgende Deskriptoren dazu, die dann beschreiben, was das für ein Audio-Device ist, woher die Glock kommt, kommt sie von außen, kommt sie von innen und so. Und den Standards gibt es schon eine Weile. Es gibt auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile die zweite Version davon, die mit ganz vielen Unzulänglichkeiten der ersten Version aufräumt. Also USB-2-Audio, USB-Audio-Version 2, so rum, die endlich auch mal beschreibt, wie das irgendwie mit Highspeed so richtig zu funktionieren hat. Die dann auch sowas wie Glock umschaltbar zum Beispiel machen. Also so ein Audiogerät kann sich theoretisch natürlich auch entscheiden, will ich die externe Glocke überhaupt haben oder will ich irgendwie auf Kosten der Qualität vielleicht auch resampeln, weil ich die Glocke lieber selber generiere? Keine Ahnung. Also hier Dinge sind jetzt sehr genau beschrieben in diesem Klassenmodell der Version 2. Und die ersten Geräte gibt es uns dann auch schon. Allerdings sind die einzigen Betriebssysteme, die das momentan unterstützen, Mac OS, auch erst seit der Version 10.6 und Linux. Windows gar nicht? Also welches Thema in der Computer werde ich auch anfassen, sobald es um Windows und Microsoft geht, ich werde den Gestank nicht los. Es ist fürchterlich. Windows hat einfach diese ganze Thematik von Anfang an völlig verbaselt. Das ist ganz furchtbar. Und dann ist jemand in die Bresche gesprungen, Steinberg in dem Fall, die sich den ASIO-Standard ausgedacht haben. Und sollte auch Ingenieure einfach keine Namen vergeben lassen. Die haben komplett dran vorbei programmiert. Die haben gesagt, Windows vorbei programmieren. Aber die ganzen Standards, die es an der Stelle gibt, von Anfang an alle kaputt waren und auch immer noch sind. Sie haben verzweifelte Versuche unternommen, das zu bereinigen und sind meisterhaft gescheit. Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn.
Dann fangen wir vielleicht noch mal da langsam an. Wir sind jetzt weit gekommen. Wir haben uns im Wesentlichen mit den Chips, den eiligen Wandern und der Theorie dahinter und vor allem mit den grundsätzlichen Problemen beschäftigt. Wir sind jetzt zumindest so weit gekommen, dass wir gesehen haben, es gibt Geräte, die über externe Busse angeschlossen sind. Diese Wandung vornehmen und dann über USB, FireWire, Ethernet, über irgendetwas, das an den Rechner anlangen. Und jetzt reden wir über Software-Architekturen. Wie wird Digital Audio eigentlich innerhalb von einem Betriebssystem zur Kenntnis genommen, weitergereicht, an Programme weitergereicht, intern gerautet? Kannst du vielleicht mal kurz einen Überblick geben, was eigentlich so die üblichen Anforderungen sind an so eine Audio-Architektur aus Sicht der Software, die ja dann letzten Endes was damit machen will? Also was muss so ein Betriebssystem eigentlich bereitstellen? Und dass wir dann vielleicht mal so dahin kommen, wie so die Ist-Situation in den drei großen Lagern Linux, Mac, Windows denn tatsächlich ist.
Also die prinzipielle Anforderung ist natürlich erstmal, das Audiomaterial so natürlich irgendwie halt aus einer Soundkarte zu bekommen und in irgendeiner Form angereicht zu kriegen. Das ist erstmal klar. Und die zweite große Problematik, die man natürlich adressieren muss, ist das Glocking wieder. Das heißt, man muss halt irgendwie damit klarkommen. Also im einfachsten Fall hat man mal eine PCI-Karte und diese PCI-Karte hat irgendwie keinen eigenen Quarz drauf, sondern generiert sich irgendwie mit einer PLL oder sowas aus dem System, takt irgendwie seine 44.100 SMPs pro Sekunde. Facelocked Loop. Also man nimmt quasi eine Eingangsfrequenz und rechnet die runter, bricht die entsprechend runter auf auch ungerade Teile und erzeugt sich eben aus dem System, takt im Rechner seine Sampling-Frequenz. Im einfachsten Falle. So, und jetzt kann man also davon ausgehen, dass wenn man so und so viele Millisekunden nach der Uhr im Rechner schlafen geht, dann sind danach eben so und so viele tausend Samples im Buffer. Weil die Clock die gleiche ist. Also, das heißt, die Systemzeit ist synchron zu der Audioglock. Das eher konstruiert das beispielsweise, weil es in der Regel nicht mehr vorkommt. Aber im Prinzip würde das gehen. So, und wie ich schon sagte, ist das in der Realität anders. In der Realität haben wir es natürlich mit externen Glocks zu tun. Sei es, weil die USB-Soundkarten irgendwie, also die USB-Soundkarten sind theoretisch auch in der Lage, sich nach dem USB-Takt zu richten, womit sie dann wieder synchron wären zum Computer. Aber USB-Soundkarten haben eben auch gerne einen eigenen Taktgenerator drin. Takten damit, funken damit ihrer völlig eigenen Freestyle-Frequenz daher. Oder es synchronisieren sich eben, weil sie es müssen, im Digitalverband mit anderen Audiokomponenten, die den Takt entsprechend vorgeben. So, und das bedeutet, dass das Audio-System im Computer sich, also der Software-Stack, in der Lage sein muss, externe Clocks entgegenzunehmen. Und da gibt es im Prinzip zwei konkurrierende Systeme, wie man das irgendwie macht. Das eine ist, man hat ein Double Buffering. So arbeitet beispielsweise ASIO. Das heißt, man hält den Buffer zweimal vor. Der eine wird gerade vom Device beschrieben. Und entsprechend von der Software, also von der Einwändersoftware beschrieben. Und ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt werden die einfach getauscht, die Buffer. Und das, was gerade eben vollgelaufen ist an Buffer vom Device, wird dann eben als Recording Stream der Applikation zur Verfügung gestellt. Und andersherum, das, was die Applikation gerade abgespielt hat, wird dann eben auf die Soundkarte kopiert. Flip Pages, man hat einfach Double Buffering und einen festen Takt zu dem, was eben passiert. Diesen Takt gibt dann der Treiber vor, der Treiber sagt irgendwie, mein Device ist jetzt dann irgendwie mal wieder eine Page weiter, und jetzt drehen wir uns einmal im Kreis bitte. Und danach erwarte ich dann auch, dass in diesem Buffer da drüben Daten liegen, die ich dem Device zurückspielen kann. Aber der ASIO-Treiber gibt quasi an der Stelle natürlich immer vor, wann das zu passieren hat. Der OSS hat auch so ähnlich gearbeitet.
Was ist OSS?
OSS ist ein mittlerweile ein bisschen veralteter Standard, der unter Linux lange Zeit irgendwie verwendet wurde. Ein System, die haben das, glaube ich, auch so ähnlich. Ich habe mich mit OSS nie so wirklich beschäftigt. Aber ich glaube, ja. Der konkurrierende Ansatz dazu ist, was Core Audio für Mac OS und ALSA für Linux macht. Es arbeitet in Ringen. Das gesamte Audiomaterial ist in Ringbuffern organisiert. Was ein Core-Audio-Treiber in der Lage sein muss, zu leisten, ist zu sagen, wann dieser Ringbuffer, der auch groß sein kann, sich über Null gedreht hat. Also, wann es jeweils irgendwie Null Uhr war in diesem Ringbuffer, wenn man sich als Uhr vorstellt. Was Core Audio an der Stelle dann tut, ist, es approximiert sich und versucht herauszufinden, wie schnell die Realzeit ist. Was es möchte, ist auf das Sample genau wissen, wo die USB oder die Soundkarte im Moment steht. Nur dann kann Core Audio in diesem Ringbuffer die Daten genau da hinlegen, wo du sie gleich erwartest in deinem Treiber und Daten schon da wegnehmen, wo der Schreibkopf des Ringbuffers quasi gerade schon vorbeigekommen ist.
Wir reden jetzt nicht über die gesamte Architektur, sondern wir reden jetzt erst mal nur über dieses spezifische Problem des Resamplings.
Wir reden über das spezifische Problem, dass der Application Layer im Betriebssystem wissen muss, wie schnell die Soundkarte arbeitet. Weil es sich daran eben alles richten muss.
Also sich damit synchronisieren muss.
Genau. Es gibt eben, wie gesagt, zwei Ansätze. Das eine ist Double Buffering, das andere ist Ring Buffers.
Was hat jetzt das eine dem anderen gegenüber für Vor- und Nachteile?
Na ja, bei Double Buffering legst du in der Größe deiner beiden Pages, die du da eben zur Verfügung hast, automatisch fest, wie groß deine minimale Latenz ist.
Ah, verstehe. Und bei dem Ring Buffer kann man im Prinzip an jede beliebige Stelle ziehen und die Latenz damit so niedrig halten, wie es irgendwie möglich ist. Aber den Buffer zumindest so groß wie erforderlich, um die Kommunikation mit dem Gerät nicht unmöglich zu machen.
Genau. Also dadurch, dass Co-Audio jetzt versucht, so genau wie möglich herauszufinden, wo deine Lese- und Schreibköpfe, die im Zweifel halt zusammen sind, sich auf dem Ring Buffer bewegen, kann Co-Audio dir ganz kurze Zeit später, ganz dicht an deinen Lese-Kopf ran, Audio-Material in diesem Ring Buffer lesen, und geht dann davon aus, dass es nicht zu nahe dran kommt, also muss man halt sich irgendwie rantasten, da gibt es dann so Offsets, die man einstellen kann. Und gleichzeitig kann es dann auch davon ausgehen, je nachdem wie genau es in der Lage ist, die Position zu bestimmen, dass an einer bestimmten Stelle in diesem Ring Buffer eben Daten liegen, die gerade schon geschrieben wurden. Das bedeutet, dass die Latenz dynamisch sich verändern kann. Wenn zum Beispiel ein MP3-Player auf so einem Betriebssystem keine großen Ansprüche an Latenz hat, da kann man ruhig mal eine Sekunde Audio-Material dahinlegen. Die kann man irgendwie dekodieren, aus dem MP3 raus, die knallt man dann dahin. Und wenn er dann vorbeikommt, dann spielt er das schon ab. Da kann man also große Buffer vorhalten. Wohingegen so Live-Recording-Geschichten mit Direct- und Feedback halten die Buffer sehr klein, weil sie das Material dafür einfach noch nicht haben. Das müssen sie erst irgendwie aus einer anderen Stelle in dem Ringbuffer lesen, dann entsprechend verwursten mit ihren Plugins und Algorithmen und dann wieder in den Ringbuffer zurückschreiben an eine bestimmte Stelle. Das heißt, da sind die Schnipsel wesentlich kleiner. Das sind die beiden konkurrierenden Modelle, wobei klar ist, dass der Ringbuffer-Ansatz wesentlich sinnvoller ist.
Das heißt, als Nachfolger von dem OSS, gibt es nicht sogar weitere Audio-Architekturen, die unter Linus eine Rolle spielen?
Auf dem untersten Layer nicht. Auf dem untersten Layer ist das, was mit der Soundkarte kommuniziert. Da gibt es nur die beiden, wobei ALSA ganz klar das Rennen macht. Das Problem bei ALSA ist leider, dass es viel zu wenig Leute gibt, die das technologisch vorantreiben. ALSA ist schon okay, aber da müsste mal jemand bei und ganz viele Dinge auch aufräumen. Leider wird da kein Geld in die Hand genommen von niemandem, weil Audio auf Linux nicht ernst genommen wird. Es wäre möglich, aber es ist einfach kein Markt. Deswegen sind alle froh, wenn ein bisschen mp3 funktioniert.
Der Scope von Core Audio auf dem Mac ist aber sehr viel größer als der Scope von Alza. Wir vergleichen jetzt sozusagen diese spezifischen Komponente auf der niedrigsten Ebene, aber auch die Kommunikation mit den Audio-Interfaces.
Core Audio ist viel mehr. Also Core Audio hat eine riesige Bibliothek auch noch im User-Space, die auch noch eine große Rolle spielt. Wir haben jetzt gerade wirklich nur den hardwarenahen Teil uns angeschaut und den Transport in den User-Space. Aber es gibt mehr. Es gibt deutlich mehr. Es gibt einen riesigen Pool an APIs, die man irgendwie verwenden kann für alles Mögliche. User-Space auch. Core Audio beschreibt auch eine ganze Plug-in-Architektur.
Keine Ahnung, also im SIG-Bereich sind sie groß, das stimmt schon. Ich meine, da gibt es ja eigentlich gar nichts anderes. Also klar gibt es natürlich noch ein paar Buden, die irgendwas machen, aber diese wesentlichen Architekturen, die wesentlichen Sequencer- Recording-Programme, irgendwie auch Audio- Hersteller, gibt ja hier auch noch Native- Instruments und was nicht alles, also da hat sich Deutschland einfach eine richtige Position erarbeitet. Apple hat sich ja hier auch die Magic gekauft, die auch aus Hamburg waren, glaube ich.
Also das mussten die auch damals irgendwie tun, um zum einen irgendwie den Windows-Schlurchen, das Logic abzudrehen natürlich, aber zum anderen haben die auch wirklich den Support von denen gebraucht, um das Core-Audio zum Fliegen zu kriegen, weil in 10.0 war das auch eine einzige Katastrophe, es hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert und die, ja...
Gut, aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz, also das war jetzt nur so eine Nebenfeststellung, dass ihr immer wieder erstaunt seid, warum Audio gerade in Deutschland so eine große Rolle spielt, wie auch immer, vielleicht liegt es ja an Kraftwerk, wirklich? Ja, kann durchaus sein und auch an Techno und so weiter, da haben wir glaube ich auch schon ein bisschen darüber geredet, über diesen Themenkomplex, als ich mich mit Tarnit über Techno unterhalten habe, wie auch immer. Jetzt erst mal so diese Systemarchitektur. Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen, also wenn Co-Audio im Prinzip den richtigen Ansatz hat und Alza auch mit dem Ring-Buffer, niedriger Latenzen, gute Anpassung an Audio-Interfaces sozusagen die Grundanforderung, die man auf der Ebene an so eine Audio- Vermittlung eigentlich stellt, gut erfüllt. Was ist jetzt da bei Windows im Betriebssystem so durcheinandergeraten, dass eine externe Company, in dem Fall halt Steinberg, da etwas etablieren kann, was alles andere de facto ablöst?
Also ich muss gestehen, ich hab's mir selber irgendwie, ich tue mir das nicht mehr an seit Jahren irgendwie, weil ich kann mir die Drogen nicht mehr leisten.
Vielleicht hat sich jetzt irgendwas getan mit Vista und mit Windows 7.
Mit Vista haben sie WaveRT eingeführt, was meines Wissens nach irgendwie diese Schnittstelle darstellen soll. Das funktioniert allerdings nur für Onboard- und PCI-Karten irgendwie. USB und FireWire haben sie irgendwie ausgeblendet, weil keine Ahnung, ich wusste sie auch nicht, dass es überhaupt existiert. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls unterstützt WaveRT das schon mal alles nicht. Und was man eben auch hat unterstützen muss, wenn man ein Windows-Driver irgendwie schreibt, ist dieses WDM, dieses Windows-Driver-Model, weil nur so kommt irgendwie dieses ganze Palim-Palim von dieser GUI bei der Soundkarte an. Und wie gesagt, ich habe mir das selber nie wirklich angeguckt, aber ich habe einige Kollegen, die die schmerzhafte Situation haben, dass sie einen Windows-Driver implementieren müssen und die sagen, das ist leider völlig kaputt. Also man hat keinerlei Möglichkeiten, Streams zu synchronisieren. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel eine Soundkarte hat, die nicht nur Eingänge, sondern auch Ausgänge hat, eine völlig absurde Anforderung an eine Soundkarte, dann muss man natürlich die beiden Streams irgendwie synchronisieren, logischerweise. Der Input gibt in der Regel die Geschwindigkeit vor, nachdem sich der Output zu richten hat und das ist angeblich in diesem Windows-Driver-Modell überhaupt nicht möglich. Das heißt, man muss im Driver dann resamplen und so. Also ob das jetzt alles, ich lasse mich da auch gerne eines Besseren belehren, wenn dann ein Kommentar, aber soweit ich das überblicken kann, ist das Unterwind komplett kaputt. Und es gibt ja ASIO, deswegen interessiert es sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Also es gibt ja irgendwie ASIO. Hat halt den großen Nachteil, dass sich eben alle Applikationen auf eine Buffer-Größe einigen müssen. Das ist in diesem Ringwaffermodell wieder sehr schön, es hat irgendwie einen Buffer und je nachdem, welche Applikation da eben langkommt, wenn es sagt, ich hätte meine Sample-Callbacks aber halt gerne für 512 Samples und nicht erst für, weiß ich nicht, 2048, dann kriegt es das eben. Das interessiert erstmal nicht weiter. Und bei ASIO ist es halt so, dass sich alle irgendwie einigen müssen. Das heißt, der mit der geringsten Latenz bestimmt quasi auch die Latenz der anderen Applikationen und erzeugt quasi auch im MP3-Player dann eine höhere Systemlast, obwohl es überhaupt nicht nötig wäre. Also das ist die große Krux daran. Aber Microsoft scheint nicht in der Lage zu sein, ein System zu deployen, das funktioniert und das irgendwie ASIO ablöst. Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was das Problem ist, aber, ja.
Irgendwas ist das Problem. Ja, was ist denn so wünschenswert? Also du meinst jetzt bei Core Audio ist das alles besser gelöst?
Na, die haben sich schon viele Gedanken gemacht. Die haben sich schon Gedanken gemacht, was die Anforderungen eines Betriebssystems sind.
Also jetzt auch über diesen Ring-Bufferkram hinaus.
Ja, also die haben sich schon irgendwie mit der gesamten Kette befasst. Die haben da schon ein System hingelegt, das ganz ordentlich funktioniert mittlerweile. Das hat schon auch eine Weile gedauert, bis sie das alles soweit hatten. Meines Erachtens hat da eMagic oder die ehemaligen eMagic-Mitarbeiter haben da wohl auch viel zu beigetragen. Und in der Linux ist Alza halt eine schöne Bewegung. Aber meines Erachtens ist die API in den User-Space zu kompliziert, die ist total over-ingeniert. Und da gibt es diverse Projekte, die sich um den nächsten Layer kümmern und die versuchen da irgendwie Licht ins Chaos zu bringen. Wir verlinken das noch in der Link-Tüte auf der RAS-Radio-CDE. Da gibt es noch eine schöne Grafik über das völlige Chaos der irgendwie 20 konkurrierenden User-Space-Liferee. Großartig, alles von G-Streamer über Lipxine und Jack und so weiter gibt es da wirklich enorm viele Ansätze. Was sich jetzt gerade durchzusetzen scheint tatsächlich ist Pulse-Audio, vielleicht das ist auch nur meine persönliche Wahrnehmung, aber Pulse-Audio als Nachfolger von dem Enlightenment Soundteam, dem ESD, scheint jetzt gerade irgendwie so in die Position zu geraten, das jetzt alles zu vereinen. Die sprechen auf der einen Seite eben mit dem Alza-System und auf der anderen Seite mit den Applikationen und können dann auch so Dinge wie Application-Level-Mixing machen. Das heißt, wenn sich der FireFox da einmeldet unter Linux und das Flashplug in Töne macht, dann geht man halt in den Mixer und dreht eben den Saft ab. Das könnte übrigens Apple auch machen. Ich verstehe bis heute nicht so genau, warum sie das nicht implementieren. Das wäre alles komplett da. Sie haben ihren Mixer da in der Mitte und den könnten sie eigentlich auch...
Also ein User Interface dafür zu bieten?
Genau.
Oder muss das erstmal eingebaut werden?
Nein, die haben einen Mixer. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, jede einzelne Applikation kann sich quasi auch so ein Mixerelement noch in die Kette basteln und hat so eine Art Plug-In, habe ich gerade vergessen, wie heißen die denn? Audio Unit. Eine Audio Unit quasi in die Kette hängen und da halt dann ein Mixer drauf bastelt. Und dann hat man halt so einen komischen Schieber, mit dem man halt die Lautstärke für diese eine Applikation lauter und leiser machen kann. Das wäre in meiner Sicht technisch kein Problem, das System weit zu implementieren, sodass man eine große Mixer-Konsole hat, wo alle Clients, die sich eben anmelden, rauskommen. Und dort kann man eben für, wie auf einem Mischpult, eben so Dinge verschalten. Eigentlich wäre das möglich.
Finde ich auch mal ganz toll.
Also Pulse-Audio kann das.
Das geht definitiv aber auch bei Windows 7 irgendwie auch aus der Box.
Das kann sein, für das, was dieses UAA, das glaube ich, irgendwie Protokoll spricht. Was heißt das noch? Vergessen, das können wir noch nachliefern. Also das funktioniert nicht für alle Applikationen schon gar nicht für die, die halt ASIO wieder verwenden.
Achso, verstehe. Wir müssen erst mal auf so einen gewissen Mindeststandard kommen. Ja, jetzt haben wir ja eine ganze Menge durchgekaut hier.
Über Formate können wir noch sprechen, welche Formate so zu...
Das stimmt, weil irgendwann will man ja das Ganze nicht nur so durchrauten, sondern auch mal entlagern und abspeichern. Ich denke, das bekannteste für Audio dürfte, also neben mp3, weil das jetzt sozusagen mitkomprimiert und von da so viel... Aber wenn es jetzt erstmal nur um das reine Speichern von unkomprimierten Audio geht, sind WAF und AEF am verbreitetsten.
Die geben sich auch nicht viel. Die haben irgendwie ein anderes Header-Format, aber im Prinzip speichern sie unkomprimiertes Audio im PCM-Format weg in diversen Auflösungen, in diversen Sampling-Frequenzen und haben eben noch so einen Header dabei, der das irgendwie noch beschreibt und sagt, wir haben es hier übrigens dann gleich ab Beidposition so und so mit Audiomaterial dieser Kategorie zu tun. In Multi-Channel auch, wenn es sein muss und so weiter. Also so AEF und WAF bieten das beide.
Ist im Wesentlichen auch eigentlich dasselbe. Es hat den selben Stamm. Ich habe mir das mal angeschaut. Das ist alles vom Amiga.
Tatsächlich?
Ja, und zwar aus dem Bildbearbeitungsprogramm. Also dieses Image-File-Format, das IFF. Das war das Format, was diese Tags eingeführt hat. Also dass man sozusagen sein Dateikontent modular bestücken kann mit eben noch irgendwas und man das eben dann taggt. Daraus, aus diesem IFF, ist dann unter anderem auch TIFF hervorgegangen. Aber diese selbe Struktur, wie die Datei aufgebaut ist, verwendet auch AIF, was sozusagen analog und dann eben im Interchange-Format ist.
Audio, nicht analog wahrscheinlich, oder?
Hab ich analog gesagt? Ja, Audio-Interchange-Format und WAF ist im Prinzip genau dasselbe.
WAF ist glaube ich ein spezielles IEF, soweit ich weiß.
Sie haben halt für ihren Intel-Satz die Beis umgedreht. Das ist sozusagen...
Indianes, okay.
Die Indianes haben sie sozusagen gleich auf Intel angepasst, damit es dann irgendwie Little-Indian ist und nicht Big-Indian. Hurra! Hätte jetzt nicht unbedingt sein müssen, aber naja okay, so ist es halt. Aber ansonsten sind sie sich eben weitgehend ähnlich. Dann gibt es halt noch diese spezifische Problem mit der 32-Bit-Auflösung, die am Anfang halt so, also 32-Bit-Adressierung, dass die Dateien halt nicht größer sein dürften als 4 GB, genau 2 GB meistens. Was ja am Anfang wie eine ganz sinnvolle Begrenzung erschien, aber heutzutage ist klar, man kriegt das eben locker voll. Gerade wenn man jetzt auf 96 Kilohertz oder sogar auf 192 Kilohertz auftritt mit 24 Bit, da ist 2 GB irgendwie gar nichts mehr. Dann wird man ja auch noch mehrere Spuren in einer Datei drin haben.
Wenn man sich das aussuchen kann, dann schreibt man lieber verschiedene Files. Aber es ist egal.
Ja, aber manchmal willst du es eben auch explizit in einem drin haben. Also wenn du zum Beispiel so einen portablen Recorder hast, der mehrere Spuren aufnehmen kann und du willst dann halt diese Spuren dann auch wunderbar zueinander synchronisiert haben, dann möchtest du es auch in einer Datei.
Da kann man sich darüber streiten, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist definitiv auch eine schöne Sache, dass du einfach eine Aufnahme einer Datei hast. Oder mehrere Monospuren.
Du erwartest einfach auch von der Gegenseite, dass man damit umgehen kann und das ist nicht unbedingt immer der Fall.
Genau, das ist nicht unbedingt immer der Fall. Also schon so diese größer als 2 GB WAFs waren schon so eine Sache. Es gibt, glaube ich, auch noch so eine Sonderart des Broadcast-WAF, wo sozusagen eine normale WAF-Datei nochmal um so einen Timecode erweitert wird, was gründlicherweise nur für diese 32-Bit-Variante der Datei definiert ist. Und dass heute so abgeht.
Also massikodieren ist quasi der Moment, in dem die Aufnahme losging nach dem eigenen Timecode.
Genau, dass die Zeit halt so richtig mal mit drin steht. Das ist natürlich bei so Aufnahmen ganz wichtig, dass man eben das weiß und das nicht nur im Dateinamen hat, weil erstens kann er sich irgendwie ändern und zweitens hat die Software ja dann so die Möglichkeit dann auch gleich anzuzeigen, ah hier alles klar, das muss um so und so viel Uhr aufgenommen worden sein.
Das ist bei Filmen vor allem halt ein echtes Feature. Also vielleicht kann man noch kurz nochmal über Timecode sprechen.
Wenn man halt Audioaufnahmen macht und dann das mit dem Film synchronisieren will zum Beispiel.
Da hat man dann wieder das Problem, dass natürlich die Kamera...
Die Zeit, die Clocks wieder...
Die Kamera entscheidet halt für sich, wenn 25 Bilder um sind, sprich wenn eine Sekunde irgendwie rum ist und der Audiorecorder entscheidet das auch. Und man hat nach maximal durch die Klappe am Anfang irgendwie den gemeinsamen Startpunkt, in dem man Bild und Ton zusammenbringt.
Na gut, es kann ja sein, dass die dann auch wirklich mit so einem Wörthclock-Kabel miteinander verbunden sind.
Ja, dann ist die Frage, wer ist der Master?
Na einer von den beiden.
In der Regel interessiert es keinen, weil die Tags in so einem Film zu kurz sind, als dass der Clockdrifter eine große Rolle spielt. Aber im Prinzip ist es ein Problem.
Welche Dateiformate würdest du denn sonst noch als wichtig erachten?
Na ja, man müsste es unterteilen in die komprimierten Formate. Unterteilen in die Loslass-Formate und die Lossi-Formate. Sprich GIF vs. ZIP, wenn man so möchte. Bei den Loslass-Formaten hat man hinterher garantiert auch wieder das Material, was vorne mal reingeschoben wurde. Bei den Lossi-Formaten geht eben ein semi-intelligentes System her und schmeißt Daten raus, von denen es der Meinung ist, dass du sie eh nicht wahrnimmst. Bei den Loslass-Formaten ist klar, wie es funktioniert. Das sind im Prinzip ein Kompremierungsverfahren, die auf Audio spezialisiert sind, also optimiert sind. Dann gibt es FLAC, das bekannteste, ein BSD-lizenzierter Codec, ein paar Russen, die meinen, nehmt unser Zeug, könnt es verwenden, wie ihr wollt. Ihr könnt auch kommerzielle Produkte draus machen, müsst uns auch nicht sagen, was ihr damit treibt. Hauptsache, wir haben einen schönen Standard. Und ein Apple-Losslass, den ALAC gibt es noch.
Das ist ja irgendwie spezifiziert. Mir fällt auch gerade ein, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht zu sehr vertiefen, weil diese ganzen Wirrwarr mit Medienformaten, Containern und Codex und so weiter, das hat hier schon mal zu weit geführt, nämlich in der Ausgabe 61, Medienformate und Codex, Karajan Express, war das nämlich schon mal ein Thema. Ich bin mit dem Bücher FireWire zusammengesessen und sind mal auch so diese ganze Historie, wie sich das alles so entwickelt hat. Da war auch diese EFF-Geschichte ein Thema. Da habe ich das nämlich jetzt überhaupt gerade. Merke ich, fällt mir jetzt gerade so ein. Und ja, also wenn diese ganze Medienformat, Container, Dateiformat-Geschichte interessiert, also da spielt auch Video eine Rolle. Chaosradio Express 61. Denke dabei, können wir jetzt auch erst mal belassen.
Ja, dann gibt es, wir sollten es schon noch kurz ansprechen, die Lossi-Formate. Also der bekannteste Vertreter ist natürlich MP3. Und die arbeiten alle, wie gesagt, mit psychoakustischen Effekten am Ende. Nicht nur reine Komprimierung natürlich, sondern weil da kommt man halt auch nur so weit wie zum Beispiel Flak. Was MP3 tut, ist also prinzipiell ganz einfach erklärt. Wenn du ein sehr lautes Signal mit einem Kilohertz hast, dann nimmt dein Ohr Frequenzen, die deutlich leiser sind und in der unmittelbaren Umgebung auf dem Frequenzspektrum liegen, nicht mehr wahr. Und deswegen entscheidet MP3 ebenso, der hört es eh nicht, also lass es uns einfach rauskicken. Und das funktioniert für Dinge, die man nachher irgendwie deploit. Ganz okay für Dinge, die man aufnimmt, allerdings überhaupt nicht.
Was meinst du mit dem man deploit?
Naja, also wenn du das fertige Format hast, den Mixdown gemacht hast von irgendwas und so weiter, dann kann man das irgendwie als MP3 schon als Konsumerformat anbieten. Aber es gibt auch Recorder, die zum Beispiel MP3 schreiben können. Und das ist meines Erachtens, wenn man das irgendwie nachbearbeiten möchte, völlig...
Unakzeptabel.
Völlig. Also speziell beim Film zum Beispiel, man macht dann irgendwie eine Aufnahme und hat die ganze Zeit so einen Dimmersurn, irgendwie bei 50 Hertz irgendwo drauf liegen. Dann geht MP3 her und sagt, ja, ganz schön prominentes Signal, das wird wohl wichtig sein. Und alles, was so in der unmittelbaren Umgebung liegt, das nimmt da eh keiner mehr wahr. Sagt, mach mal was raus. Wenn du hinterher dann versuchst, in der Filmmischung dann irgendwie dieses Signal dann rauszuziehen mit irgendeinem scharfkantigen Notch-Filter, dann ist halt auf einmal gar nichts mehr da in dieser Frequenzumgebung. Und das ist natürlich genau das, was du nicht wolltest.
Verstehe.
Also deswegen, mp3s Rekorden eignet sich für ganz, ganz wenige Dinge nur überhaupt. Und wenn man dann halt den fertigen Mix hat am Ende, dann kann man halt darüber nachdenken, dass als gut kodiertes mp3 da noch irgendwie rauszugeben. Aber sobald man es in irgendeiner Form nachbearbeiten möchte, ist mp3 das völlig falsche Format.
Das gilt aber dann auch genauso für die anderen Losleskes, die AAC etc.
Die sind dann zwar nur ein bisschen besser, aber es gibt ja auch Rockwarbys und so weiter.
Das ist genauso destruktiv.
Genau. Da fehlen hinterher einfach Informationen, die vielleicht wichtig waren, wer weiß.
Man weiß ja nicht, wofür man es mal gebrauchen kann, so eine Frequenz.
Ja, dann gibt es noch die Deployment in 35mm-Film. Also auch da gibt es ja Digital Sound im Kino zum Beispiel. Auch da sind die in der Lage, da brauchen wir vielleicht jetzt nicht drauf eingehen, aber die codieren digitales Audiomaterial zwischen den Perforationslöchern auf beiden Seiten des Films. Und sind da in der Lage, so etwas Ähnliches wie ein QR-Code, so sieht es aus, ein bisschen abzubilden. Und die haben dann optische Sensoren in den Projektoren, die sich das wieder angucken und das wieder zu digital Audio machen. Das ist ein Abenteuer.
Blöd, aber es ist zumindest perfekt synchronisiert.
Genau, das ist in der Tat richtig. Das andere Format ist, ich weiß gar nicht genau, ich glaube DTS macht das so. Die liefern das Audio-Material komplett asynchron aus, auf CDs oder DVDs. Und man muss dann also irgendwie so zwei CD- oder DVD-Player permanent füttern, irgendwie abwechseln mit Audio-Disketten. Und die müssen dann synchronisiert werden zum Projektor mit Timecode und so weiter. Und dann hat man eben Surround-Sound über zweieinhalb Stunden.
Volles Programm.
In 5.1 und so weiter. Die haben sich irgendwie für den Weg entschieden, weil das natürlich die Auflösung zwischen diesen Perforationslöchern natürlich auch natürliche Grenzen hat irgendwann. Kriegst du nicht beliebig viel Daten unter.
Wie ist denn das mit diesem Surround? Vielleicht kann man damit ja auch mal das Inne einleiten, aber das entretet mich jetzt nochmal, ob es da noch einen digitalen Aspekt gibt. Ist da irgendwas standardisiert, wie das so abzubilden und abzuspeichern ist, diese Surround-Geschichte?
Ja, man kann im Prinzip jedes Format hernehmen. AC3 zum Beispiel eignet sich dafür. Das ist ein Lossi-Format auch, das aber in der Lage ist, mehrere Kanäle zu codieren gleichzeitig. Das Problem mit Surround ist an der Stelle viel eher, dass es nicht wirklich einen Standard gibt, wie Leute zu Hause irgendwie in ihrer Heimkino-Anlage Surround konsumieren. Selbst bei Stereo ist das schon schwierig. Es gibt eigentlich nur eine Position, von der man ausgehen kann, die optimal ist bei Stereo. Das ist der sogenannte Sweet Spot, also im dritten Punkt eines gleich schenklichen Dreiecks zu deinen beiden Stereo-Lautsprechern. Wenn du da sitzt, dann hörst du halt optimal Stereo. Und selbst das tun die wenigsten Leute. Und Surround ist meines Wissens nach nicht standardisiert, wo die Boxen zu stehen haben, wo die Leute sitzen. Vielleicht sitzt ja auch einer hinten irgendwo, keine Ahnung, direkt irgendwie an so einem Rearspeaker und kriegt dann irgendwie da die ganze Zeit hauptsächlich den ab. Also es ist ein großes Problem. Da wird auch viel rum experimentiert. Es gibt Systeme, die haben Lautsprecher in der Decke oder so, um halt bestimmte Effekte zu erzeugen. Und ja, so. Also mein Kenntnisstand ist der, dass es da nicht wirklich halt ein Standard gibt und deswegen halt auch nicht so richtig klar ist, wie die Studios zu arbeiten haben, um dann halt, also wovon die ausgehen, wie zum Schluss eben konsumiert wird. Also ein bisschen. Aber was generell so standardisiert ist, ist halt, dass es wenigstens fünf Boxen gibt. Das heißt, einer vorne in der Mitte, einer links, einer rechts. Dann hat man drei und zwei noch hinten. Ich meine, links und rechts sind fünf. Und Punkt eins bedeutet dann der sogenannte Low Frequency Enhancer, LFE.
Die Bassbox.
Genau, der irgendwo stehen kann. Also das nennt sich dann fünf. Aber es gibt auch sieben Punkt eins. Ich glaube, es sind dann in den Seiten nochmal zwei. Ich weiß nicht genau. Keine Ahnung. Ja, die letzte Sache, die wir vielleicht noch kurz ansprechen können, ist Timecode. Es gibt halt diverse Möglichkeiten, Timecode zu transportieren. Das spielt halt, wie gesagt, speziell dann auch eine Rolle, wenn du Bild und Ton zusammenbringen willst.
Was gibt es da?
Da gibt es dieses SMPTE.
Wo man SMPTE sagen möchte, ne?
Genau.
Hat das also nichts mit E-Mails zu tun?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Das ist schon immer der Standard eigentlich für Timecode?
Nee, das ist ähnlich wie ASEBU. Und eigentlich bedeutet SMPTE auch nur Society of Motion Pictures and Television Engineers. Und man meint damit aber, wenn man über Timecode spricht, den standardisierten Timecode, der in der Lage ist, verschiedene Frame-Rates an Bildgeschwindigkeiten und so weiter zu repräsentieren. Dann gibt es diese fürchterliche Entwicklung der Drop-Frames, was mit NTSC zusammenhängt, als NTSC irgendwie erfunden wurde, haben sie es irgendwie nicht geschafft, sich genau auf 30 Bilder die Sekunde zu einigen. Stattdessen sind sie bei 29,97 Bildern die Sekunde gelandet. Und deswegen muss man in diesem Timecode-Format dann in jeder ersten Sekunde, wie war das dann, in jeder ersten Sekunde, jeder Minute die ersten beiden Frames droppen, aber nicht in Minuten, die zehn teilbar sind. Irgendwie sowas.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Schaltjahr.
Ja, genau, hat mich auch daran erinnert.
Oh Mann.
Das kommen wir jetzt auch kurz mal an. Das ist quasi ein...
Das mögen die Amerikaner gerne, solche Standards. Beim Telefon, Digitaltelefon machen sie es ja auch so. So T1-Leitungen und so weiter mit ihren 1,54 Gigabit, wo dann irgendwie das Inbau und Signaling drin gemacht wird. Egal, da kann man sich auch nochmal die passende CRE-Folge zu anhören. Dieser Timecode ist aber sozusagen schon der universelle Standard. Das ist dieses SMPTE, das ist das, was überall verwendet wird, was irgendwie alle Formate definiert. Aber wie kommt denn das dann bei Digital Audio? Wo spielt denn das eine Rolle? Ist so etwas wie Timecode in irgendeiner Form vorgesehen in Core Audio oder ALSA? Spielt das da irgendwo eine Rolle? In den Dateiformaten?
In den Dateiformaten schon, ja. Du kannst halt irgendwie bei den Broadcast-Web zum Beispiel eben den SMTPS MPTE-Timecode notieren, bei dem für dich irgendwie die Aufnahme losging, was dann interessant wird, wenn du hinterher eben verschiedene Aufnahmen zusammenbringen willst. Also da gibt es auch die absurdesten Ansätze, irgendwelche Geräte, die man an einer Mutter-Uhr eicht und die man dann auseinanderbringt. Und eines davon hängt man an den Sound-Recorder, eines an den Bild-Recorder und am Ende im Schnitt hofft man, dass man das irgendwie wieder zusammenkriegt.
Also ein bisschen wie so olympisches Feuer, was man dann durch die Gegend trägt, ja?
Na ja, das spielt vor allem dann eine Rolle natürlich, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wenn man ein Live-Konzert über zweieinhalb Stunden aufnimmt und jede Kamerada mit ihrer eigenen, in ihrer eigenen kleinen Glockwelt lebt und jeder Sound-Recorder dann auch und so, dann musst du hinterher in der Lage sein, irgendwie das alles wieder zusammenzubringen.
Okay, aber in so einem Audio-Setup gibt es dann für diese Timecode auch nochmal einen extra Stecker.
Das ist... Das Wort-Glock meinst du?
Oder? Nee, ich meine jetzt so...
Schon Timecode. Ja. Ja, da gibt es so komische kleine Mini-BNC-Stecker, so vier, fünf PIN drin, ich weiß nicht genau, die so bessere Audio-Rekorde eben auch in der Lage sind, auszuspielen.
Hier ist sogar von Cinch-Kabel die Rede.
Also man kann diesen Timecode auch über diverse Kanäle transportieren. Es gibt auch das LTC, der Longitudinal Timecode, den man dafür hernehmen kann. Das klingt wie so ein Modem, das sich irgendwo kommuniziert. Der Timecode wird quasi als Audiosignal übersetzt und dann auf einer Kamera beispielsweise aufgenommen. Man hat einen kleinen Camcorder, der nimmt den LTC-Timecode auf und dann rennt man mit einem anderen Gerät durch die Gegend mit Audio auf. Diese beiden Glocks, die beiden LTC-Timegeber sind aber synchronisiert zueinander oder wurden mal synchronisiert und laufen dann pro Tag irgendwie nur so viel auseinander.
Dann hat man in der Audiospur keine Audio, sondern die Tonnen, die Zeitcode und auf dem anderen Audio-Recorder das selbe auf einer Spur.
Dann hast du hinterher wenigstens irgendeine Chance, das zusammenzubringen.
Pfiffig.
Und den VITC, den gab es vor allem als Vertical Insertion-Timecode. Das bedeutet, dass in der Austastlücke von Bildmaterial der Timecode gespeichert wird. Also quasi dann, wenn der Kathodenstrahl von unten rechts nach oben links zurückzieht, dann steht da diese Lücke im analogen Bildsignal. Und an der Stelle hat man eben den VITC dann gepackt und hat dann den großen Vorteil, dass man ihn auch auslesen kann, wenn das Band steht zum Beispiel. Man kann es quasi frameweise hin und her spulen, man hat pro Frame irgendwann mal ein Timecode.
Weil er halt immer an der Stelle da ist, wo er sein soll.
Genau. Aber über diese ganze Film-Audio-Synchronisierung und Postproduktionskette kann man natürlich auch eine eigene Sendung machen.
Ja, da haben wir jetzt unser Pulver eigentlich ganz gut verschossen, oder?
Ich denke auch, das reicht mal.
Ist kein neuer Rekord, hat ja keine Hoffnung. Oder?
Ich mache mir eher Sorgen, wenn sich das alles anhört.
Ja, es gibt immer wieder Leute, die warten, ob am Schluss noch irgendwelche Coupon-Codes ausgegeben werden oder so. Aber gibt es heute nicht, habe ich nicht vorbereitet. Aber immerhin, wieder mal ein ganz ordentlicher Ritt hier durch ein Thema, Digital Audio.
Und garantiert auch die Hälfte vergessen und hoffen Fehler gemacht.
Ist ja alles auch nur der Versuch, erstmal zusammenzufassen, was man eigentlich alles so lernen kann. Das ist ja für mich hier auch so die Lernleistung meiner letzten fünf Jahre. Ich glaube, ich habe über nichts so viel gelernt wie über Audio, aber ich merke auch immer wieder, dass es noch so ein riesiges Feld ist. Alles, was man irgendwie nicht mit 12 bis 16 Jahren irgendwie in sich hineingeschaufelt hat, das kann manchmal echt schwierig sein. Ja, mal gucken. Aber ich denke, das gibt noch mal eine ganze Menge her. Aber interessant fand ich jetzt vor allem diesen Digital Audio Aspekt, weil ich denke, das sind immer so viele Sachen, wo man einfach eben am Anfang eigentlich gar nicht damit rechnet, dass man überhaupt in so viele Probleme reinlaufen kann.
Naja, das ist echt wirklich interessant. Weil es erstmal so viel einfacher klingt und nonlinear bearbeitet werden kann und so weiter. Man kann hin und her spulen und alles copypaste und so.
Aber am Ende des Tages ist einfach mal so ein geiles Lichtgeschwindigkeitsanalog-Audiosignal. Das hat einfach so eine Qualität. Das kann ich echt verstehen. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt mit meinem Mischpult hier, so einem Digital-Mischpult, quasi so in den Zwischenweg gegangen. Das Ding arbeitet halt intern als Blackbox halt digital und hat dann sozusagen den Vorteil für mich, dass es eben diese ganzen Verluste nicht hat. Und es gibt hier nicht so viel Übersprechen. Und es ist natürlich alles speicherbar und abrufbar und pipapo. Aber es ist am Ende halt auch rattenschnell. Und die Signale laufen halt rein und raus analog, ohne dass man groß merkt, dass es zwischendurch digital war. Aber das setzt natürlich dann auch eben eine hohe Integrationsqualität voraus, die solche Teile halt haben. Na gut, Daniel, dann machen wir jetzt hier mal Schluss. Ich sage Dankeschön. Ich auch.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Und ich sage auch Dankeschön fürs Zuhören. Und ja, das war's. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.